ladies and gentlemen today this is a
rough day man um you normally were doing
pre-production about an hour before the
show we have a bunch of stories
throughout the day that we're looking at
what we're planning on talking about and
then we like to come up to the studio
make sure the lights and the cameras are
working and think about what stories we
got but today there was a tornado
and it was directly due west
heading directly due east
and so we we got the warning that the
tornado was coming and we're like okay
so we got to bring everything inside and
we're rushing and then we're worried
about the chickens like what do we do
with the chickens and so we're actually
we're we almost brought them in as well
but tornado didn't pass us however it
was pretty like i don't want to say it
was scary because i've dealt with
tornado warnings before but we actually
had you know the mail service you know
the mail carrier came out here and they
were like heads up the tornado this is
legit like people are freaking out now
we're in a mountainy area so it probably
broke it up a little bit but the it
passed just north of us so so we all
good we're all we're all alive and we're
doing the show and uh but i tweeted and
i'm just basically saying this because
in the event people saw the tweet want
to know if we were okay we survived and
uh for some reason we lost the internet
we had to like fix the internet but that
was probably due to the storm i guess
but uh we're here and we have news
biden is uh uh not doing too well his
ratings were ridiculously low for his
his his speech not really a state of the
union and we're seeing tv ratings
collapse now some have argued this is
good it means joe biden can sneak
through all this ridiculous spending
right under the nose of the american
people and i hate to say it but i think
most things go under the nose of the
american people because they're not
paying attention so what's really
happening is good news
sort of democrats traditional liberal
types the voters aren't paying attention
they've gone to sleep
that means republicans who are still
fired up and angry the anti-woke and
defected liberals
are still on the offensive and the
democrats have lost their their support
base so we're going to talk about this
we got a bunch of other stories too it's
it's getting scary out there if you're
paying attention to the cost of goods
gasoline lumber uh wood uh it's it's
skyrocketing in price at the same time
cryptocurrencies are going way up so
we'll get in all that as well and then
we got some crazy news too apparently
doctor strange for those marvel fans
doctor strange wasn't in one division
maybe you don't know what those those
things are this is a show on disney plus
do you know why doctor strange wasn't
included in the show
it's perhaps because he's a white male
no joke apparently that's what the
reporting we're seeing is so uh yeah
we'll talk about that too and joining us
today is the editor-in-chief of the
post-millennial libby emmons how's it
going it's going really well you want us
to give us a quick uh brief intro sure
uh i'm libby emmons i'm the
editor-in-chief with the post-millennial
we're a uh
canadian
center-right publication cover a lot of
american news a lot of culture stories
andy noe was around you know is our
editor at large oh okay cool yeah it's
great to work with andy right on yeah so
uh we'll be talking about stuff yeah
we're talking about lots of stuff and
things excellent and he's chilling yeah
hey everybody ian crossland over here
i'm excited to get to the bottom of this
joe biden saying no what no one that
made four hundred thousand dollars yes
it's gonna have to
pay a penny
taxes they got this one of the reasons
his ratings are probably down at least
they're hoping is that the man can't
speak
joe biden was like nobody who makes
under four hundred thousand dollars will
pay a single penny in taxes i'm like
does that mean that like you gotta pay
taxes up to 400k he must have met a
penny more than they used to pay no it's
legally binding he said it okay thanks
joe
yeah i was wondering what kind of taxes
is he talking about is this just income
taxes or can we get in on some sales tax
like what are we doing yeah yeah he's
basically saying like he's paying no
taxes make all the people who make more
than 400k he's gonna make him pay like
70 percent and then everyone else pays
nothing right all right and somehow he's
going to keep those people in the
country i don't know how sounds like a
plan
socialists to come up with i guess right
people don't understand economics but we
got to we got lydia she's pressing all
the buttons i'm in the corner as well
i'm hoping that none of this penny that
has to be paid according to joe biden
applies to me as well i guess we'll see
free money hey before we get started
head over to timcast.com and become a
member we have a lot of work going on
with the site right now and upgrades are
coming soon new payment integration
options but you go to guys.com you click
that members only button then you can go
to the members area we have a huge
library of exclusive members only
content some full podcast episodes we
had a great discussion with michael
knowles you may be a fan of his from the
daily wire about god faith and religion
spirituality just weird
and you know
just really interesting weird i i throw
that out there because like ian comes in
with like the correlation between the
metaphysical the physics and religion at
the same time so that's where it's like
really and i mean i mean we're in a good
way like interesting conversation so go
to guest.com check that out don't forget
to like share subscribe the notification
bell and if you're listening on itunes
or spotify or wherever else on podcasts
leave us a good review give us five
stars and share the show with your
friends it really helps let's take a
look at the first story of this op-ed
from joe koncha over at the hill
he says biden's poor tv ratings against
trump is exactly what this
administration wants
i don't agree but the point joe is
making is i believe it's a fair point
though i do disagree he basically says
you know we know that trump was just
desperate for ratings and he was well he
didn't say desperate but like bragging
about how good his ratings were then we
see joe biden his ratings are in the
gutter nobody wants to watch the guy
nobody wants to watch cnn or msnbc
because they built a network on hating
trump and binding just ain't it but he
goes on to mention that with all this
massive spending he says 1.9 trillion
for coveted relief 2.25 trillion in
infrastructure with nobody paying
attention to what biden's doing he can
just keep doing these things and no one
will stop him i don't like the argument
because who is going to stop him anyway
mitch mcconnell he's not going to do
anything and all they really need the
democrats for is the rage vote and then
like clockwork the traditional liberals
go back to sleep i experienced it in
2008 we're watching it happen now
this is good news for disaffected
liberals moderates conservatives trump
supporters and whoever else on the right
because this means that
with liberals going to sleep declaring
victory but only on a very very slim
victory
well the republicans in 2022 will likely
take the house and maybe even in 2024
we'll see what happens but uh i wonder
what y'all think about joe biden's
inability to make anybody care about
what he's doing
i think it's actually really interesting
i think we saw a bunch of that after the
election right for there there were like
two weeks where it seemed like we were
just all going to celebrate um
biden's victory that the country was
going to open up it seemed like that was
the
deal that was being made that the nation
was being held hostage to abide in
victory and then you know sure enough
they came crashing back down and locking
everything up again
which actually seemed way worse than the
first time
but i do think that liberals have
pretty well gone to sleep because they
figure that they've got their guy in
their guy is going to do the right thing
and that's that they were so invested in
hating trump that anything that's not
trump they think is good and so they're
not actually applying any critical
thinking power to these policies that
are being enacted they're not looking at
what horror it's going to implement in
the u.s i wonder if they ever actually
cared at all you know i know i know
people who have no business being in
politics like people who sure who didn't
vote no 8 12 or 16 who all of a sudden
were like filming videos of themselves
where they're like i gotta put my ballot
they're like are you doing your duty
with your ballot and i'm like dude you
have no idea what you're talking about
you're just doing this because the guy
in the tv said to do it is that is that
really it's tribal so after that trend
what's the next trendy thing to do it
certainly is not joe biden no one cares
about him no one cares about joe biden
but i do think it's interesting too we
had in the fall we had aoc we had bernie
sanders and other progressives
complaining that joe biden wasn't going
to be far left enough that he wasn't
going to install the progressive agenda
and now we're seeing them basically
celebrating you have hillary clinton
saying he's doing a bang-up job you have
aoc saying that he's really being much
more collaborative with progressives and
i think that the conservatives that um
held their nose and voted for joe biden
i think they were played you know they
believed that joe biden was was just
going to be
ineffectual
um you had bill crystal talking about
how this was going to be the way to
install and create a new conservatism
that all of this stuff was going to be
easier for conservatives with trump out
of the way and instead they were
completely steamrolled you know it was
like a total bait and switch
they voted for a moderate guy who wasn't
going to do anything and instead they
got this progressive guy who's just
spending all the money and then some but
like he's still not progressive enough
for the actual socialists
well aoc seems happy about him so far
she said the other day before his his uh
his state of the union there well you
know does does aoc actually have
principles or is she just like a stop
she she's like a um
of pressure relief valve for the
democratic party yeah in the event the
woke left becomes too disaffected she
then goes like and they're like oh we're
satisfied again so
yeah i'm not sure if she has any
principles she goes on for long periods
of time on instagram live and we can try
and sort it out although uh so much of
it seems like
just straight nonsense there are rumors
that because new york is losing a
district they're going to get rid of
hers have you heard that i have heard
that is it but is that true or is that
just i don't know i mean people thinking
whoever's in charge would get to
re-redraw the districts and the
democrats are in charge so they could
redraw the districts and they could draw
out a republican district instead right
yeah that makes way more sense i mean
aoc has fallen in line she's she like i
said she's the stop she's a pressure
release valve for for the democratic
party the progressives get too angry she
comes in and she does her you know
finger snap and then acts like nancy
pelosi should get votes and then votes
for nancy pelosi while pretending like
she doesn't like nancy pelosi she gets
her whole crew on board i don't think
joe biden is
a socialist
the socialists the actual like you know
bernie dsa types think joe biden is a
fascist just not as much of a fascist as
trump and i'm like
okay maybe you know whatever i'm
sure joe biden is not a good guy he's
corrupt he's crooked he's pro-war all
these really awful things so sure i
guess i'll give him that one
but to say he's not enacting far-left
policies when he's just like money
printer go burr just cranking out yeah
he's very clearly yes he very clearly he
rescinded the executive orders on
critical race theory he sure did and now
they have a new thing going through to
more like mandate critical race theory
in school that's right yeah and that's
pretty weird and you have you i'm sorry
i'm sorry you mean to teach black
history
uh no no no no reuters reuters says it's
about teaching black history we have
black history black history is essential
the civil rights movement is of course
monumental achievement in american
history um but that's not what they're
talking about they're talking about like
you mean reuters lied to me
did you see the headline from reuters
i'm not going to say that i don't want
to get fact-checked reuters reuters said
republicans ask biden to end his
divisive policy on teaching black
history it is the most insane propaganda
i agree and this stuff has been coming
up in schools for a while i think it's
only recently though that parents have
been seeing it and that's why people
have been able to speak out against it
oddly enough it's because of remote
schooling that parents were able to see
this stuff i know that that happened in
my house right so my son
kicked out of school march 16th with all
of the other 1.1 million school children
in new york city
and hardly any of them are back still i
think the uh we recently reopened sort
of uh middle and high schools but it's
there's like 300 000 kids back in
schools basically the last the last
number that i checked um which was maybe
a month ago actually but um
once my son came home
and i started seeing what was going on
in the classroom it wasn't really a big
deal until after george floyd was killed
and then i heard his teachers say that
they were going to have a day talking
about um
i think it was a day talking about
white privilege
um
and another day talking about uh
uh you know what happened and everything
so i set up my voice recorder to just
record what was going on on his call
and i recorded
hours of this conversation um
where the white kids were basically and
he was actually the only white kid in
the class so where
the white kids were basically told that
um they didn't even know that there was
racism in their family that their
parents
didn't know that they were racist that
their grandparents didn't know that they
were racist and i'm looking at our
family and i'm sure lots of parents did
this as well
my son's grandmother was a public
defender in philadelphia she defended um
move members i don't know if you guys
know who that is she defended um
you want you want to briefly describe oh
so move was a black nationalist
organization
they were in west philadelphia they were
targeted by the fbi and the city they
were eventually bombed in this horrible
situation i think it was 85 maybe
um they were bombed by a black mayor who
teamed up with the fbi uh
and um so that's what is that your mom
who definitely no no no that is my son's
um dad's mom yeah and she defended the
move members she defended yeah i believe
she defended eddie africa wow uh yeah
but the teacher said that this is this
is a racist person this racist family um
my grandmother was a public school
teacher in brownsville brooklyn in the
40s
her parents were immigrants but i mean
it doesn't it doesn't even matter what
your background is right i mean the idea
that a teacher should be
telling you that your grandparents are
probably racist and
that they don't know it and that you
don't know it and that this is just the
passed down legacy through your family
on the basis of your skin color is
absurd that a teacher should be telling
a kid that anything is a product of skin
color or race
is
completely anathema to the civil rights
movement that is that is
what should be being taught right you
know what's really funny about critical
race theory
when you look up the wikipedia for it
they have to define what white supremacy
means because it doesn't mean what
people think it means so it actually
says crt is loosely unified by two
common themes first that white supremacy
exists and maintains power through the
law they then add in parentheses after
white supremacy societal racism
right because in the language of the
cult members when they say white
supremacy they don't mean what 98
percent of americans understand it to be
that
a white supremacist is somebody who
believes white people are superior or
supreme they've just changed it to be
now just
objectivity and right history being on
time being on time as white supremacist
um yeah i think it's sort of interesting
too because the new definition of white
supremacy means that there can be no
way to educate yourself out of it
there's no way to have forgiveness
there's no reconciliation at all it's
just it's a permanent condition
until you know and looking at something
like systemic racism basically the
entire society needs to be dismantled
before that can be repaired and we're
looking at a
you know set of theories that
the people who support them
the idea would be you have to dismantle
society but they're not offering any
anything to rebuild it on right it's
just a completely destructive idea i
agree and i often refer to it as a
chaotic and destructive force because
there's no real rules like is women
offensive today because you've got to
say wemmick sin but then whimxen is
offensive because it excludes certain
women and i think maybe the reality is
there may be competing interests in
terms of what comes next the one thing
they all agree on is destroy the system
destroy the system but i do think many
of those who say who claim to be trained
marxists don't want to tell you what
their actual solution is
because people would revolt if they
found out what these people were
planning and so they say we got to tear
down white supremacy and everyone goes
that sounds pretty good to me and then
first of all they don't mean literal
white supremacy they mean some
ridiculous nonsensical term they say
we're anti-racist which doesn't mean not
racist doesn't mean not racist it
literally means be racist and then they
say diverse which also is just another
you know diversity inclusivity and
equity are just more buzz words that
don't really make a lot of sense and
then that's the halfway right after they
burned all to the ground
what they want is probably you know
moral authoritarianism they have control
they can have whatever they want you go
live in the gutter i think that's really
interesting too and i think
conservatives pushed away from
having any sort of moral compass
after the
90s christian right
takeover of congress with newt gingrich
and all of those guys and the
conservatives were pretty well slammed
at that point for having a moral
perspective and having it be a christian
moral perspective and having that be
oppressive and the wrong thing to do and
after that conservatives embraced
um relativism
in a very real way
you know the liberals were embracing
relativism anything you do is fine if
that's what you want to do which to a
certain extent you know
there's nothing for it people are going
to do what they want to do whether you
want to judge them for it or not but
the conservatives left a vacuum of moral
authority and of moral perspective and
it's been filled with something that has
actually no
um
no basis right so if you look at for
example a relig let's take a religious
moral perspective you could have the ten
commandments in there right that could
be a basis upon which you're making
determinations you could use the
beatitudes and the gospel according to
matthew as a basis to make
determinations which is basically
be really kind you guys right but when
we look at the
contemporary leftist
um
moral
framework framework there's no
foundation there's no basis i agree so
it's just this shifting sands of a value
system that is whatever you want it to
be whenever you want it to be it so long
as you can use it to maintain your own
power it's like a hologram
yeah it's like it's like a hologram of a
religion right i was reading this book a
long time ago i don't know how true any
of this stuff is it was like a book on
quantum physics and they talked about
how the chemical properties of an
element in this probably up your alley a
chemical property of an element is based
on the amount of electrons is that like
you know so hydrogen is one helium is
two yeah and so they said something
interesting happened when they were
working on circuit boards when an
electron got trapped in you know this
one part of the board where there's i'm
probably totally ruining this concept
maybe you guys listening understand what
this is i was writing a book this is
like 10 years ago they said they were
sending electrons through you know
pathways in a circuit board and they had
they had an area where basically the
electron got stuck in a you know small
space and it began to orbit nothing
but it began to uh
repre exude the chemical properties of
hydrogen with no nucleus oh interesting
and so i think about that again more of
ian's alley in this regard but it's it's
it's vaguely similar in that
that's what that's what i feel like we
have with critical race theory it's
missing the nucleus core component of a
real moral framework like you can
disagree with religions and what these
people believe but there's like as you
mentioned a foundation to where these
ideas come from how they've persisted
this long bad ideas go away good ideas
remain become stronger and then you look
at woke and it's hollow well it's
because there's no there's no synthesis
right there's only woke there's only
this
this critical race system or this gender
critical you know um
not gender critical that's
a little there's that critical theory
critical theory let me point something
out real quick too i am partly bothered
by how many people just keep saying
critical race theory over and over again
ignoring critical gender theory that's
part of it too critical theory as a
whole critical theory
and the problem is that because of the
way that it's constructed in society you
can broach these ideas but you can't
broach any opposition to them because if
you broach opposition to them then
there's something wrong with you and you
are you know a racist or transphobic or
whatever of the other things are that
you could be labeled you're a bigot in
some sense of the word um but unless
these critical theories are challenged
there's no synthesis to the better idea
they just stand there on their own and
they need to be challenged we need to
challenge every idea that we have and we
need to be challenging our ideas all the
time
you mentioned uh how your son was in
school he started to wake up and stuff
this this brings me to this next door we
have from the post millennial ooh
anti-critical race theory candidates for
school board when overwhelming support
from dallas parents candidates who ran
on an anti-critical race 3 platform won
two open school board seats in dallas
south lake district on saturday with a
landslide almost 70 percent majority i
mean that's the bulk of the story i
think again it's heavily focused on race
theory and i think a lot of parents are
actually having a bigger reaction to uh
gender theory because the gender theory
is definitely coming down the road and a
lot of that originated in british
columbia in canada
um yeah and that you know you have the
gender unicorn and the gender
gingerbread man and it's been pushed
very heavily ginger person the ginger
yeah gingerbread peppers not gingerbread
man of course
gender bread mix them or whatever you
know with the but i think
but yeah there's a couple things that
have happened here and i'll you know try
to be as respectful and delicate as
possible for youtube and their censors
but uh there have been lawsuits
the the parents of young biological
females concerned about
their opportunities in
athletics resulted in lawsuits yes we
recently had caitlyn jenner who is a
trans woman come out and say that it was
unfair but i think things like that so
not to derail too much but it's not just
race theory parents are learning about
all of these different things and saying
hey you know wait a minute it's not fair
to discriminate against someone based on
their immutable characteristics that's
correct and it's also not not right to
tell someone that their immutable
characteristics need to be changed in
order for them to be who they really are
since i wrote the story this summer
about my son's
education
a lot of parents reached out to me from
across the country to tell me about
their experiences and i had a mom in
california telling me about the
gender education that her child was
receiving and she had actually gone to a
school board meeting and had seen the
slides
of
the way that the curriculum was going to
be implemented from kindergarten all the
way through
12th grade
and it starts off with a book about a
boy who wants to wear a dress
and it moves right through you know
gender transition
altogether and she moved her kid to
texas
in order to get away from this and i've
recently been talking to a lot of
parents about how things are going with
regard to reopening schools we had this
promise from joe biden that schools were
going to be reopened at the end of 100
days and it's just not actually true the
schools are not open
are you shocked it's shocking this can't
be right it just can't be real ian do
you believe that joe biden would lie to
us
[Laughter]
um and it turns out so my question
started to be what does open mean what
does that mean to you you know what are
your feelings about it my personal truth
in the word open means closed right it
turns out that you would be correct uh a
lot of the schools are still closed
schools that were closed in the fall are
still closed schools that were open in
the fall are still open so the idea that
anything
that biden has done has actually
resulted in reopening schools is
complete farce
i think we got to move to florida
everybody just just we keep talking
about that at post millennial moving
moving to florida we keep being like hey
let's just all move to florida i don't
want to derail just yet but we will be
talking about this new this new bill
that's on the verge of getting passed
which is going to change the game in
terms of social media and what it means
for you guys
but uh we'll we'll keep it on you know
the critical race here in the school
stuff for now we'll get to that later
but yeah
i think a lot of parents realized this
and i think what we're seeing is
interesting with this one story that you
guys a lot of people wrote about the
story but you know the one we just
pulled up
this is a district that uh narrowly went
for biden by i think like it was like
five point swing so it was like 47 for
trump 52 for biden
the county went for trump so you know it
depending on which which metric you use
you can make an argument but i think
when you're looking at these suburbs
which they said white affluent suburbs
actually went for biden more and trump
actually lost white voters and gained
latinos and black voters
the fact that you have white affluent
suburbanites pushing back against this i
think this is where we see traditional
liberals falling asleep and then those
who are forced to wake up
really waking up and swinging a 70-point
you know lead for the anti-critical race
theory yeah what do you think could
happen in 2022 when these traditional
libs are just not paying attention and
the disaffected liberals who are are
like
what is happening
there keep being more disaffected
liberals i used to work in theater and
i've heard from people who don't want to
be named and don't want to be public
but they reach out to me and they're
like hey this stuff is crazy and i'm
like dude
i know i have been telling you for a
while that this stuff is crazy
and they don't want to believe it
because they were so married to their
ideology
and you can't be married to an ideology
there's there's just no sense in that
you constantly have to question it if
you don't know why you believe what you
believe then why do you believe it it's
really interesting talking to uh someone
who's particularly religious like i was
talking to michael knowles man like like
i mentioned we got over at tmps.com this
longer bonus segment with michael
talking about religion for like an hour
and ian we're talking about space and
everything and it's really fascinating
and then after even even after the show
you know we're hanging out just chilling
and having this conversation
michael knows a lot now maybe it's not
fair to compare like your average
liberal to someone as well read as
michael knowles but every conversation i
have with someone who is
religious
and like legitimately they can tell me
some things about it why they believe it
i understand there are a lot of people
who are probably just like i don't know
and you know i wouldn't say that they're
you know i don't know it it exists but
if i take
the average like
i'm trying to avoid calling people out
but we've spoken with people even on
this show who could not tell us what was
going on with critical race theory why
they would support it or oppose it
granted destiny actually really did so
there's a you're familiar with destiny
right yeah
he actually knew a ton about it and
actually articulated why he was four and
i was impressed with that because i
talked to a lot of people who have you
know prominent channels and they're like
well i mean it's just like you oppose
racism right and i'm like is that what
you really think like did you actually
read any of this stuff like we're
looking at you look at some of
christopher ruffo's research and it's
like
a laboratory sending white people on a
retreat to condemn white people like
that's against this violation of the
1964 civil rights act yes so i started i
talked to so many conservatives about
religion and they'll talk about what
this saint said or what they learned in
you know this chapter or this first like
they actually did some research or
reading and then i talked to my my
liberal friends who are following the
stuff my progressive friends and they
don't know anything about the roots they
don't know anything about where it comes
from or what it means and i think that's
really i think it's interesting i think
it says a lot i think it says a lot
about our educational system
i think it says a lot about um you know
where all of that stuff landed so the
people who are liberals now were
educated in a college system in a high
school system you know that um
basically gave all of this stuff as
gospel this is what you were supposed to
believe and what has happened is that
critical race and gender theory and i
would even say
you know the concept of climate alarmism
these are all concepts that are opinions
right and they are dictated to children
and children
form have the opinions by rote they have
the opinions before they have the
information
so
they take their opinion and then once
they're taught the actual information
they already have been told how to think
about it
so
that's not
you know that's not going to be
effective in terms of creating people
who can think for themselves you need to
provide the information and then you
need to say these people think this
about it these people think this about
it what do you think about it synthesize
that information synthesize the opinions
think critically about it yourself and
come up with what you think and if we're
not doing that we're just creating a
generation of stupid manageable children
you know i was uh on the way back the
other day i was thinking about i can't
remember exactly what happened but maybe
think about this but
people just don't care about their
community anymore and so you mentioned
these are opinions being dictated to
children
more than you probably realize i think
most of these things that we learn are
actually opinions but they're expert
opinions right there's a difference
between like some regular guy in the
street being like the sky is you know
made like the clouds are made of
marshmallow and you're like okay dude
that's not an opinion that's like crazy
and so there are things we believe to be
fact there are things that are fact
when it comes to science we have the
challenge of trusting people and so when
it comes to a scientist telling you what
a cloud is it's like have you ever
really gone up there and actually
like done the research to prove it
that's water vapor you haven't but most
people reasonably conclude some things
are true like if i throw a rock at a
window the window will likely break
there's a fact when it comes to a lot of
things that we teach children they're
actually just expert opinions based on
available data that's why science
changes so often right so i guess it's
it's it's fair to say to a certain
degree we we we suspect these things are
facts science eventually it's that point
but what's happened is
this this understanding of history and
science is being exploited by what i
refer to as the cult i think
there's a case of cult is because it's
like a religion with no nucleus no moral
foundation right so what they see is
hey wait a minute when you tell these
kids something based off the available
data it's an expert analysis that you
believe to be true
now obviously some things are tested and
there are control groups there are some
things we don't have control groups for
which make it very difficult notably
climate change right there's no control
plan it's very difficult however i i do
fall into the category of someone who
believes climate change is an issue i
think humans mass consume will will lead
to serious problems to me that just
feels like based on everything i've seen
it kind of mathematically adds up to
this point however that's just me
trusting it's also me just giving me
giving an analogy like my personal
analysis of someone who reads the news
for a lot of these scientists they're
experts who have the availability of
lots of data and can draw a conclusion
but this is why science is often wrong
exploiting that system is very easy and
that's what the critical race theorists
the critical theorists are doing the
difference is there's actually climate
data now
granted some people don't agree with it
don't believe it i have anything that's
incorrect but when it comes to critical
race theory what you have there is
we made up a thing that we think is true
we think one race is you know mean to
the other race there's no hard data
there's no numbers we can argue numbers
we can argue science around you know ice
shelves or something like that well but
with critical race theory they're taking
data from
you know 50 70 years ago and they're
using it as though that data is still
relevant for society today
and that's a big problem it's like it it
completely
eradicates the civil rights movement uh
maxine waters saying that the country is
getting more racist every day she's a
she's a sitting congresswoman from the
state of california and she has been for
a very long time she's a lot of power
she's a pretty bad job of ending racism
i guess yeah she you know and you have
biden talking about systemic racism well
he's been in federal government since
the 70s where has he been what has he
been doing about it oh he was making
that sustainability he was you know
working on it i guess real hard the
other direction um
yeah you know i just don't think that
anyway all of this stuff is being taught
um
because the people who are teaching it
have an agenda and not the people who
are teaching it but it's coming down
even be from not from the teachers
themselves like in new york city you had
uh and he's not there anymore but you
had richard karanza who was the school's
chancellor and he was basically
dictating this kind of education he was
saying that it had to be that way under
the obama administration we had common
core curriculum come in which basically
what it does is it teaches the same
subject uh like the same sort of content
in every subject so in math you're
learning about racism in english class
you're learning about research well
common core what it does is it links all
of the things that you're learning
around sort of um one kind of subject so
you're learning about one thing in all
of your disciplines
um and that you know that's something
that happened under that because it was
supposedly easier to study
study things that way but when you don't
allow teachers to design their own
curriculum i think that's a problem we
have really intelligent teachers
they should have a little more say over
how the they educate the kids in their
charge i think you know
just to touch on the point i was making
when you talk about racism and privilege
it's impossible to quantify they can say
something like white people are stopped
this many times and black people are
stopped by police this many times and
that doesn't prove or mean anything
you'll hear from the left they say
that's proof of racism and then you'll
hear from you know the right that's
proof they're committing more crimes
right so it is interesting because
simply by by nature of getting arrested
does not mean that you know black people
are committing more crimes however it
also doesn't mean that cops are being
more racist it's what's the
determination so the left chooses what
they want to believe cites the data and
claims the data is true based on their
personal argument about it and i think
that happens a lot with data i think
data can be used to be proved to prove
whatever it is that you want it to tell
you
um john mccorder talks about this he
talks about how
the uh you know
difference in percentage is very similar
to the difference in percentage of
poverty the difference in percentage of
crimes committed is different is very
similar to it's like the same percentage
i think he said it was 2.5 percent
um and he's a you know he's a
fascinating thinker as well but i think
that that's a big part of the problem is
people just use the data to construct a
narrative that they then support with
everything else that they're doing
decide that those are facts
and then perpetrate them i see that a
lot in the climate science arguments
when it's like saying there are six
sandwiches and you eat one sandwich a
day in six days we're not gonna have any
sandwiches everybody in six days we're
out but they take no account of outside
influences that someone might bring a
delivery of sandwiches that we can
figure out how to reuse the sandwich
well you had john kerry recently saying
that we had nine years left until the
end of the world he said something like
that
and he was parroting what aoc had said a
few years back when she said there were
12 years left
and a reporter
asked jen saki the white house press
secretary if there were nine years left
and she said something like i don't have
anything else to preview for you on that
and it's like
do you really think there's nine years
left until it's the end of the world i
and that is what alarmism is right like
we used to use whale oil for everything
um we used whale oil in lamps and to
make you know what was it tallow candles
oil yeah like well that's moby dick
right ruby dick was it was a was a book
about energy consumption and like
harvesting energy
so we hunted whales to near extinction
that was a big problem until we found a
new energy source and then we could you
know congratulate ourselves for saving
the whales we would not have saved the
whales if we didn't find some better
energy source people don't understand
this too i was reading about slavery
slavery didn't end because of some moral
imperative from good people right it
ended because of invention the cotton
gin yeah yeah
and they're like there were good people
trying to end slavery i mean the
abolitionist movement was a
i think an important moral perspective
absolutely a lot of really amazing
people and one of the bloodiest wars
ever fought to end slavery but the
catalyst was
for a lot of people
they're unwilling to give up their
comfort
so they were it wasn't until people got
access to cheaper goods and no longer
needed it that they were all of a sudden
having this moral epiphany about why it
was so wrong to do right the romans
never ended slavery yeah well so we
saved the whales just like you mentioned
it was only once we didn't need them we
were all of a sudden like oh hey you
know you got to save the whales now so
then the question becomes are these
sustainable energy resources that we're
plunking so much money into and
demanding that we remake our society in
service too are they really energy
efficient enough to do what needs to be
done to you know further humanities
interests are they wind and solar not
alone not alone and we're shutting down
nuclear energy plants right that's
that's not smart and i don't think that
is super smart i think that's sort of
dumb and we're shutting down nuclear
energy plants because why because the
baby boomers it made them feel icky
do you know about the the manure
the projected manure crisis of new york
no so i guess at the turn of the century
1800s to 1900s there were
i guess scientists and individuals
warning that due to population growth
that the cities would have you know six
foot piles of horse crap everywhere in
every corner because people needed
horses horses take dumps and when you're
going through the city and the city's
growing there's going to be too many
horses so they're generally concerned
about it
then the car was invented
and then and then it was okay and then
all of a sudden right so so
i suppose the issue is
you know i i think it's fair to say we
we have to keep close a close eye on
what we do as humans because to think
that we're invincible or immortal i
believe would be stupid
but also we should be heavily focused on
advancing technology i agree not
shutting it down and so unfortunately
for us it's a key component of the left
to oppose nuclear energy like even tulsi
gabbard i'm a big fan she opposed
nuclear energy and i was like i think
you i think you could convince her if
you actually show her the data modern
nuclear technology nuclear modern
nuclear technology is fantastic it's
carbon neutral it's a massive energy
return on energy invested
and it's something we should be doing
right and i think
and we completely discount the waste
that is inherent in sustainable energy
those wind turbines they die they can't
be reused you know they're going to
litter the landscape the kinds of
materials that are used to create solar
panels you know what's in those things
how are they constructed i don't think
that
i don't think we're actually considering
um
you know the side effects of any of
those things we're just assuming that
because it's sun and wind and those are
friendly and filled with flowers it's
all okay have you seen the original iron
man
no i gotta squeeze in my pop culture go
for it so the original iron man they
have a you know stark comes back from
the desert you know he built this thing
called an arc reactor he's with obadiah
stain who's the spoiler alert it's been
you know what 13 years he's the villain
and they're looking at the arc reactor
it's like just gigantic you know glass
cylinder thing
and
tony says to him he's like look we you
know we should look into arc technology
and obide says we built that for the
hippies the thing was never cost
effective
that's that's how i feel with a lot of
the investment into photo photo voltaic
solar
and a lot of wind
wind can be great but
you can't use it alone you what happens
when the wind is is weak what happens
when you don't have battery power so
it's a good it's a good supplemental but
there has to be a stronger robust backup
system one of the problems with
photovoltaic voltaic this is solar
panels right because there's also other
kinds of solar energy that can be
generated so like mirrors reflecting
into big vats of like salt water or
something well there's the passive solar
versus the pvs yeah so one of one of the
people one of the things people don't
realize about photovoltaic solar as it's
a luxury item for wealthy people well it
sure is i learned this when i actually
talked to a solar company and i was like
it's gonna be great it's gonna save me
money right and they're like no
they're like maybe in 20 or 30 years
they're like but the reality is people
get these because it's a backup system
and i was like what and i was like i
thought we were getting this because
it's going to reduce our energy
consumption and they were like
i mean
a little bit but the amount of carbon
and energy put that is used to build
these things you're not going to get
that back for a couple decades
so hopefully
you know we're getting better and better
energy output from our photo photo full
photo voltaic you can just say pvs pvs
there we go pv technology um it's
getting better and better and maybe
we'll get to that point where it does
become immediately more cost effective
but people need to understand
the machines to tram transport wind
turbines
burn in carbon and you need lots of big
trucks to move these massive things we
don't have enough superconductors to to
get this energy where it needs to go we
don't have enough
you know energy storage so even when you
have pvs on your roof and everything
like that you're still sending the
energy back to the grid it's not off
grid
it's just your generating you're like
your own little power plant generating
energy and sending it back we we ended
up not doing solar i was kind of bummed
and the main reason was they were like
yeah you'll have it's like a generator
and i was like so if i just do like a
diesel generator it's better faster
cheaper and i'll waste less energy
because you fill up your diesel tank one
time and you never use it that's right
and then it just sits there for you yep
and so they were like
yeah but you know maybe after 20 years
and i was like but won't there be wear
and tear for 20 years won't i have to
deal with like getting the roof fixed
taking these things down they're like
yeah yeah and i was like okay
well you don't want to put pvs on a roof
that's going to need repair exactly and
so you know uh they do this new thing
with tesla they're called solar shingles
and
it's
when i actually talked to them about it
the the the function of a roof
the repair is needed it just didn't make
sense i mean there's a lot of cool
technology the question is should we
base our entire society on it should we
spend all of this money to re-educate
everyone so that this is the only thing
they know how to do
i i don't think that's a great idea not
necessarily no
the problem is
like you you look at these marxists they
talk about marx and his writings about
the future and where humanity ends up
and um and and they they love to cite
star trek and that's very offensive to
me it's a huge star trek why is it
offensive they they claim that the
federation in star trek is communist oh
i don't think it is it's not communist
it's not coming people have beachfront
property there's federation credits
there's there's hierarchy but you can
choose to serve or not there it's
classically liberal it's it's a very
liberal classically liberal society and
you can still have your own vineyard
it's exactly
and they've created
and they have uh they they've ended
scarcity through replication that's what
changed their system but i digress
that's just a story but these communists
like to claim that's the future that
mark's envisioned the communist future
and i'm like
sure maybe
but marx didn't unders like
what you guys are proposing won't exist
until we invent replicators things that
can literally pull ambient energy from
the air and convert energy into matter
maybe once we have that yeah we don't
have that right
and so all of these people who are
talking about
the future green energy i'm like maybe
we're just not there maybe we should be
putting all this money into fusion
technology well or maybe we should be
you know allowing a little bit more of
the market to decide how things go
instead of using
moral cuddles to destroy some kinds of
energy generation and to bolster other
kinds it doesn't seem like um
i just don't think the federal
government should be involved in
determining how we're all going to be
living and working
if you look at it that way it just
doesn't make any sense well i'll give
you the um
i guess predictable centrist position
i don't think the free market can can
solve the issue for the most part like a
like a totally laissez faire just open
go you know go for it because i think
we'd end up like yeast in a bottle just
farting ourselves to death you know what
works in the short term is and
eventually we hit a wall and then there
may be a point where we go off a cliff
however a command economy absolutely
doesn't work some random bureaucrat
deciding we're going to build this thing
makes literally no sense well and it's
joe biden and his his cronies deciding
that we're going to do it this way and
you don't see data as to why it should
be done that way all you hear is that
this is compassionate somehow it's
compassionate to the earth or its
emotional manipulation
and i don't think that the um using
compassionate as compassion as a as
they're just beating us to death with
our own compassion um and that's true
with the
the race stuff and the gender stuff as
well don't you feel bad for everybody
well sure i feel bad for everybody okay
well then you have to
do all of these things to ameliorate
yourself feeling bad for everybody and
that's when you st that's when you see
the liberals start to fall asleep they
figure i've done the right thing
now i get to live how i please you know
everyone else is going to live how they
are they please and they're not
realizing that remaking society
in this way
is just going to destroy it but it works
on conservatives too
once enough people fall for the
emotional argument the hard-line
conservatives fall in line because they
have no choice well they don't know what
else to do and they're not really being
supported i mean we're looking also at a
i think a um
sort of schism in conservatism now right
so you had the
bow tie wearing we were talking about
for the bow tie wearing
socially liberal fiscally conservative
types
who just wanted to sit back and get
their tax breaks and not really worry
too much about anything else and let the
rest kind of just roll along and they
did that and this is the society that we
have and now you have a new group of
conservatives um and i think you're
seeing it in a lot of independent
conservative media as well
and they're say they're much more
socially conservative
they're more fiscally liberal but not
with regard to the same causes that the
liberals are pushing and i think there's
going to be a split like if we do see
2022 if we do see
conservatives taking the house back
i think we're going to see
the new conservatives doing it we're not
going to see these old style
lindsey graham
you know mitch mcconnell type of guys
doing it milk toast mitch that's what
i'm calling we're not yeah i mean we're
not going to see those that that style
of conservatism is not coming back and i
don't think it should i think it was
sort of arrogant and boring and uh
didn't really take into consideration
what it turns out half the population is
interested in i just realized mitch
mcconnell actually reminds me of the
original milk toast character casper
milk toast
yeah so that's you you're familiar with
where it's concentrated i i was not i'm
just always impressed that i can spell
it it's an old comic about a guy who is
like deferential and weak and milk toast
because the artist considered that to be
just like the most boring breakfast you
could have milk
and so it's just like he's just an old
man with glasses he has a mustache you
know mcconnell doesn't but i look at
mcconnell you know
we like to joke i'm the milk toast
defense sitter tim poole centrist
whatever but the reality is i
get heated on this we you know on the
show talking about say 2a or taxes or
billionaires manipulating elections but
mitch mcconnell what is he doing what
does he ever really do yeah i mean he's
trying to push back on this critical
race theory thing but i don't only only
after they lose everything
yeah i don't think he's gonna win he was
also um pushing back against trump i
think rather substantially and lindsey
graham only came around after it turned
out his constituents wanted him to
support trump and lindsay will walk up
and high five kamala harris well he'll
do whatever he has to do to stay in
office i think that's pretty clear but
we have some good news for conservatives
though this might change the game here
we got the story from the hill florida
passes bill prohibiting social media
companies from banning politicians
it's way more than that i don't i don't
think people realize that sb 7072 now
there's some really interesting weird
stuff they put in it they like amended
it to include if you have a theme park
you're excluded from this or something
well disney's kind of cool right
so what is facebook uh face park
facebook will open space park
and twitter will open twitter world to
try and get past this because it's not
just about politicians this also
protects news organizations so this is
fascinating i've got i've got sb 7072
pulled up and it's kind of annoying to
go through the whole thing
but it also has something to do with
like antitrust let me see if i can just
pull up a journalistic enterprise there
we go
check this out
journalistic enterprise according to
this new bill means an entity doing
business in florida that publishes an
excess of 100 000 words available online
with at least 50 000 paid subscribers or
100 000 monthly active users
publishes 100 hours of audio or video
available online with at least 100
million viewers annually that's us
and the other one is you the
post-millennial
i'm pretty sure you have more than a
hundred thousand monthly active users
you probably get that on a single
article i'd imagine yeah
that means
if you were operating in florida
wikipedia could not remove you from
sources you could not be banned from
twitter
so
let me let me make sure i pull this up
because there have been some changes
but my understanding is that
a journalistic enterprise can't be
banned based on their uh
opinions the content of their articles
so
so that would be like the new york post
was was uh suppressed and banned on
facebook it was banned on twitter
their account was taken down for a
little while that was in the fall with
the hunter biden stuff
i think that was so interesting i think
that opened a lot of people's eyes to
what was going on
with social media and with suppression
and with you know fact checking
and with the control that social media
companies really have in the marketplace
of ideas right now
they can decide if an idea lives or dies
or is exposed to the public or not i
think desantis is pretty fascinating guy
i appreciate that he just goes for it on
so many policies i liked what he did
with his whole covet thing he was just
like nope
what concerns me about
this uh bill is that people will just
stop operating in florida like if i ran
facebook i'd be like all right not
operating in florida yeah i found it
interesting i found it they say a social
media platform may not take any action
to censor d-platform or shadow ban a
journalistic enterprise based on the
content of its publication or broadcast
post prioritization which is the
algorithm of certain journalistic
enterprise content based on payments to
the social media platform by such
journalistic enterprise is not a
violation of this paragraph this
paragraph does not apply if the
conditional material is obscene as
defined in
s847001
so there's some exclusions but
this will be the end of wikipedia as we
know it do you think yeah let's just go
down so this wikipedia i don't think
should be protected by section 230. no i
don't think so either so because i don't
think that i don't think they are a
platform i think they're clearly a
publisher well so for uh specifically
let's let's let's jump over to the
critical race theory article we already
had pulled up oh let's take a look it
says critical race theory from wikipedia
the free encyclopedia
it doesn't say from user joe joe bob jr
or jim joe bob jr that's joe biden he's
joe bob
you know joe biden's actually joe bob jr
yeah joseph robinette biden jr anyway
digress it says from wikipedia
so my argument is just because i submit
a comment
if if i if i comment to the new york
times and they publish it an article and
it says the new york times you know
article and then it puts my words there
like that's from them right not from me
so this is interesting wikipedia
won't allow you to use certain sources
i'm probably i'd be willing to make a
substantial that the post-millennial is
not a lot of wikipedia
i think we have an entry
no no i mean like your articles right
can't be used oh they can't source
citations
no because they'll say it's not reliable
really is that right can we not be used
as a source i don't know about you
specifically i bet so there's a lot of
boundaries
that are not allowed media matters is
considered credible but biased news
guard considers media matters a-ok
credible but wikipedia has a lot of
sources that are deemed not credible and
they can't be used
or if they're not certified credible you
can't use them either they'll
they'll challenge these news outlets
okay can't do that no more under under
this new bill in florida
if your organization operates in florida
wikipedia can't remove your content on
the ba you can't remove your stories in
the basement basis of the content
so perhaps they could argue no no we've
banned the outlet outright right what's
the reason for banning the outlet we
don't consider them reliable why don't
we don't consider because of the content
they pop up
the bill says you can't do that which
would mean
you would look at critical race theory
anything
could be added from the post-millennial
anything could be added from gateway
pundit or from the daily wire or the
thing that you end up with though is you
end up with editors on wikipedia you end
up with the uh you know it you you can
end up in weird wikipedia wars where you
go in and change something and then the
editor who had it there in the first
place goes in and changes it and these
can this can go on for a long time and
this is where the interesting lawsuits
erupt with this sb 7072
they say that users have to be given a
bunch of special provisions like they
have to be informed as to why they're
being removed they have to be given
access to all their data made available
immediately if they don't they can be
sued
i think as soon as desantis signs this
you're going to have you know
jim bob with one follower sign up or
zero followers
post something outrageous get banned and
immediately file a lawsuit and then they
will get slammed by probably hundreds of
lawsuits overnight they won't be able to
deal with
well what would happen then in the
courts i mean what how would they deal
with that well so we have a defined
system aren't they isn't it like yes 100
100 000 fine or ten thousand dollar fine
depending on if you suppress
either that or they'll just open
everything up and not ban anything and
that would kind of be
i think a better situation i think
that's probably the goal of it is to
have just have a much more free and open
ideas
so the library online there's a funny
meme
where it's the npc meme you ever seen it
where it's like the npc face and then a
guy responds and then angry npc face and
he says my opinions are being censored
on the internet he's wearing a mug ahead
right and then the uh the normal guy
says and what opinions are those and
then the npc gets an angry face what
they're trying to imply because there's
other memes that are similar that
conservatives
are only complaining because they're
racists
right well that's always the argument
but it's not true no but it also doesn't
matter if it's not true because once you
get called some of these things there's
no way to walk it back you know there
was a what was it like a couple of years
ago or whatever there was this weather
man
who said the wrong thing and he didn't
mean to say the wrong thing it was just
the way that his mouth formed the words
they were there it was like it was like
a a freudian portman two of two words
right but he didn't even mean it it was
just it was like a weird linguistic
thing and john mccorder who is a
linguist at columbia university um came
out and said actually this is a pretty
common thing that happens this is a
weird way that your mouth moves the way
that language sort of works in your
mouth it was like a very and dude lost
his job but so so the issue is because
it didn't matter
like it doesn't matter the only thing
that matters are the appearances well in
a very shallow culture right now right
right right but in this capacity what i
what i'm bringing up is conservatives
getting banned for their political
opinions
it's not just because they're racist
like you get banned for saying learn to
code for criticizing journalists they
will remove you from these platforms
many people who did not break the rules
but were bombastic got banned from
social media and they claimed some
arbitrary or or you know vague
understanding of the rules notably in
the case or outright lies according to
james o'keefe right because they banned
him
supposedly so twitter says for operating
multiple accounts and james is now suing
them for this right i thought that was
really interesting too and i think he's
got a lot of nerve for doing that i
respect it absolutely and you saw they
launched pv legal so no no i didn't see
that so actually we had james on the
show uh-huh and i mentioned maybe we do
something like the people's defamation
defense fund or something oh great and
then james was like i'm gonna go do it
so he did it
so sweet good for him but the the main
point is conservatives lose
they're going to lose because they're
excised from political discourse trump's
some of his biggest supporters were not
allowed to rally people and communicate
and post online they got banned across
the board right and the most extreme
leftists were allowed to stay on and say
crazy and lazy you say crazy things
violence call for violence organizing
violence well and there's all of these
antifa accounts as well that just call
for you know when there's going to be
protests and things and tell everyone
where to go
um and then show up and that you know
this is something andy noe works on a
lot
with um another one of our reporters mia
caselle and they're tracking this all
the time they're tracking these
uh
you know events that are just organized
out in public
and then you had the situation with um
you know the capital riot the january
6th which is of course the worst thing
that has ever happened in this country
since the civil war you guys so just be
aware of that yeah you heard that right
so the president said it so it's got to
be true um
but
after that you had like this massive
purge of people you had them taking down
an entire social media platform
saying you know they took down parlor
from
amazon took it off its servers it got
banned from
the app stores uh i think it's back now
but
the idea was that all of this horrible
stuff had been planned online on parlor
and it turned out to be primarily
planned on facebook and nothing happened
to facebook did they maybe crack down a
little more i don't know
twitter sure did but
you know there's just no accountability
on the left at all it's just assumed
that if they miss something then that's
just in good faith and they're trying
really hard
and they're so clearly come down on the
on the conservative side conservatives
need to stop cooperating in their system
the way i see it is imagine you're
playing monopoly with someone and
they're the banker and they just like
reach in and pull out a 500 and put in
their pawn you're like yeah i just saw
you took that money they go end right
and then you're like okay whatever i
guess right look dude like imagine
you're sitting around like five people
this is how i play monopoly with my son
he's like mom i'm taking money out of
the bank
so imagine you've got five people and
you're sitting there watching the banker
take the money you're going dudes he's
taking the money out he's cheating and
then he looks you in the eye as he hands
100 to the friend in the front his
friend goes i don't see anything right
it's just like why are you gonna keep
playing this where you've got the banker
and the media together and the
politicians right but here's the
question
what other game is there the
conservatives allowed culture to just be
thoroughly created by the left
all of the platforms everything are
created by the left and then as soon as
they create one it gets banned it's
because when the game started we started
playing monopoly
this left this goes uh or this democrat
could say democrat sure i'll be the
banker and everyone went sure and their
public goes like i don't know about that
whatever i guess
and then they play a game and they cheat
and the conservative goes like
i'll win next time and they cheat again
right meanwhile the conservative could
have been like hey at least two other
people playing this game are
conservatives you guys want to go play
katan or something right and just walk
away and go so now you see the daily
wire making movies sure which i think is
great right exactly i think that's topic
playing their game stop trying to pander
to these people they're not going to let
you in the club but then what happens
but then what happens too is we have a
complete polarization of media so now we
basically have like when i talk to you
know liberals they don't even read the
same news that i read they don't even
see the same things when i go on to um
you know i think i was saying before
there was a i saw a panel
conversation on one like cnn or msnbc or
whatever it was and it was yamiche
alcindor uh who's pbs white house
correspondent and a couple of other
people and they were talking about how
the gop is the party of fear that
they're trying to make everyone
terrified and they're playing culture
wars games and i'm looking at this and
i'm going your guys just told me that it
was a patriotic duty to wear a mask
and that i need to be terrified to send
my kid back to school until literally
everyone in the country is vaccinated
and you're telling me that
us saying that you know critical race
theory is not a great idea is is us
being this party of fear it's absolutely
ridiculous we don't see the same news we
don't consume the same media at all the
tr the traditional liberals don't watch
the news at all they're getting their
news secondhand oh absolutely you don't
think they're reading the times every
day washington post absolutely not and
that's why they're clueless about what's
going on that's why they just follow the
trends and that's what trends that's
that's why they go back to sleep the
moment biden wins i think that they are
reading the times every day i think they
are reading wapo and they're watching
cnn and they're consuming all of their
media this way they're watching rachel
maddow they're doing all of that stuff
and that's where they're getting their
you know that's where they're getting
their confirmation that they're correct
i think i think it's people like
following alyssa milano
do people really follow alyssa mulligan
millions followers did you see how she
got destroyed the other day by that uh
lady on tv
that was pretty sweet because is a
hardcore unrepentant racist and i mean
that literally right i'm not i'm not i'm
not she also totally betrayed the whole
me too thing when she was like well tara
reed's probably basically a big liar you
know it's like okay you you like alyssa
well done i love how rose mcgowan is
always calling her out right rose is
great spectacular um you know and she's
not a big fan of republicans she
criticizes them as well but alyssa said
a whole bunch of really really racist
things and that woman yeah black women
calls her out
for saying like she like alyssa milano
basically said that all black men are
criminals like just really hardcore
racist stuff but from with like this
this this pandering could you imagine
like kind of voice like condescending
and race at the same time it's brutal
she also was wasn't she snapped wearing
a crochet mask because that's really
going to keep the spike proteins out so
why why you know it's the crazy thing to
me i know i know celebrities they hit me
up actors and musicians and they're like
oh i better not say anything and i'm
like you
why why do you want to hang out with
those people that's just craziest thing
to me i don't understand that either and
um
you know there's this idea so
what are you supposed to do if you're
with people that you disagree with are
you supposed to keep your mouth shut or
are you supposed to just speak up and i
think that if everyone would just speak
their mind it doesn't have to it doesn't
have to be a big conflict to speak your
mind like
somebody says i think this and then you
say oh i totally disagree with you i
think this let's have another beer or
whatever it why does it have to be such
a big deal to disagree with people
because they don't read the news they
follow alyssa milano
but i i mean this generally not
absolutely like obviously some of them
many of them do watch the news cnn's
ratings are in the gutter and it's
because people don't care anymore right
but when liza milano says something i
looked i looked to the people i know in
chicago my old like many of my friends
or people i grew up with were
progressive or liberal who could not
tell me
anything about politics except they can
tell me about systemic racism
what you know the trump is bad you ask
them why and they can't really give you
a reason well trump is bad because he's
orange
well they'll say like dude he lies right
i'll tell you what a conversation
an actual conversation i had with
someone is i was like you know someone i
know back in chicago trump's a liar
there's no question and i'm like what
did he lie about and they're like oh
come on dude you know he lies and i was
like yeah i agree
what do you lie about
like yeah well the people who hated him
couldn't name any policies that he had
pushed forward except for the one family
separation policy which was a terrible
idea and was i think in place for maybe
a month or two but this is why they
don't like conversation
because they don't have any answers and
they know that the moment you say oh
that's an interesting point tell me more
they go uh
i can't right i just alyssa milano
tweeted it so i just repeat it i have no
idea and you're like oh no one even
knows if that's true but there's there's
this desire to be in that club and it's
really really weird to me i think those
people also couldn't name any of biden's
policies although it is interesting that
we were talking earlier about biden's
ratings which are
really poor but the um
they're really poor primarily among
republicans and high among democrats
except with regard to the border and
democrats are also rather dismayed about
the border situation biden has that new
um hardcore libertarian policy i don't
know if you guys saw but biden went just
absolutely
relative relative to the current
position of the establishment it's it's
libertarian he said anyone who makes
under four hundred thousand dollars will
not pay a single penny in taxes and i
went whoa
let's just go for it right on the lead
sounds great
i'm i'm i'm actually uh a big fan if if
he wants to raise the tax on people
making more than 400k and it means
everyone underneath literally like under
400 no one pays taxes
you go ahead and do that with my
blessing we'll see how that we'll see
how that goes out i'd like to
grandfather that in too it's legally
binding the president said it that's
like um hammurabi
he undid debt for everyone he wiped that
clean for all yeah all the libertarians
started like laughing when biden says
this i could imagine taxation what i'm
interested in his face on it so what's
going to happen when all of the outlets
run stories about how biden said no
one's going to pay taxes and all the
facts and all the fact checkers are like
we you didn't add enough context he
because he didn't mean it
you can read his mind apparently right
well that's the thing that whole thing
i didn't set it up all in like let's
stop but that whole thing about like
reading the politician's mind because
you assume that they agree with you that
started under obama remember obama came
out in the first place saying that he
wasn't in favor of gay marriage and then
all the people i talked to were like oh
he just has to say that so that he can
get elected
anything that they disagree with he just
has to say that so that he can get
elected it's like
that uh the leftists during the obama
administration normalized the idea that
a politician should be speaking out of
both sides of their mouth and that that
somehow is a good thing look at hillary
clinton right you got to have your
public and your private positions right
so you mean lie to the american people
lie to everybody
why would your private position be the
lie it's like oh now that all the
cameras are off i actually do support
helping the poor turn the camera on the
poor are awful
at least michael bloomberg was honest in
that regard when he said tax the poor do
you remember that i don't remember that
but i do
as a new yorker i do think michael
bloomberg did an awful lot for the city
yeah i really do
well his policy in new york was tax to
the poor because they don't know what's
good for them so it's better to take
their money away and then give them
services like the soda tax and all that
i was not in favor of any of that stuff
i was in favor though of how much money
he pumped into the new york city
department of parks and recreation we
had a massive parks building spree under
his administration all through the outer
boroughs it was like giuliani bolstered
manhattan and bloomberg really raised a
lot of the quality of life in the outer
boroughs don't you have an election
coming up
yeah
isn't yang like on top yang is i think
uh he's doing a great job of like being
a goofy new yorker you know he and his
wife will go out to dinner and they'll
sit in that so we uh
restaurants are like sort of mostly open
but they all have these like uh little
pods you can set it out on this cycle to
eat bugs in to eat bugs and some pies
but like uh there were some photographs
of andrew yang and his wife out for her
birthday sitting in one of these pods i
spent a good portion of the winter going
out to dinner with friends with these
heat lamps and the restaurant would give
you blankets and we'd be like and more
whiskey that's necessary it's in the
snow drinking outside
new york sounds like
hell right now
people say that
i love new york
yeah i mean
you know new york's like it's kind of
rough you know what happened is uh so
violent crime i think has increased 45
percent 2020. that's not great the
subways are really a lot worse
than they were that's not great our
leadership is garbage our schools are
like sort of barely open
um
but soon we're going to be able to sit
at bars
that happened yesterday so that's
exciting that's crazy to me because out
here you can just do it yeah you can't
just do stuff in new york in west
virginia
if you go to
a like corporate store you got to wear
mask because the big corporates like
mandate it but if you go to any small
business they tell you to take the mask
off and that yeah i'm like well cool
well i mean it's it's the policy of the
local businesses because in in these
areas they actually got rid of i don't
know about how west virginia's handling
the total mass media but maryland got
rid of their outdoor mass mandates so
in so so we're in an area where it's
like maryland virginia and west virginia
west virginia life is totally normal
right like no one's been affected by
this nobody cares there's like some
limited restrictions you know but the
big corporate stores typically mandate
it from a corporate policy perspective
virginia pretty much does the masks and
maryland outdoors not so much
inside you do though in new york city
there's mask mandates and all of that
but we have absolutely no enforcement
earlier in the pandemic the nypd was
called upon to enforce the no gathering
rules
um and i was talking to a guy at the
nypd and he was like yeah so the optics
were of us arresting
black and latino people for having
barbecues on their front stoops and we
gave that up basically instantly wow so
there's just no enforcement i don't know
if you saw there was a guy who was uh
showing up on tucker carlson all the
time who had a bar in staten island yep
so the reason the guy in staten island
kept getting all that enforcement is
because uh cuomo was able to use the
state police in staten island the nypd
were not enforcing at all they weren't
enforcing closures they aren't enforcing
masks they aren't enforcing gatherings
they're not enforcing anything they're i
mean it's hard to find a cop uh these
days um i've seen a couple more of them
in the subways
shootings have skyrocketed morale is
really low all of that but they're not
enforcing masks so i would not want to
be in one of these cities do you see
that video of the guy at disney world or
land or whatever and he's crying no
yeah so it's like a guy with a woman and
she's filming and he's just bawling his
eyes out
and it's just there there really is
i don't i don't know what's happening
but the culture war divide it's not
necessarily left versus right that is a
big component of it it's how you might
describe the tribes but boy are there
really different two different groups of
people yeah
yeah
speaking of cities also um we don't hear
much about this but in montreal i have a
lot of co-workers in montreal there's a
curfew of 8 p.m
grown adults are forced back into their
homes at 8 pm and they you get ticketed
if you're out
um
like big tickets like 1500 tickets and
there's been large protests against
these lockdowns but it doesn't seem to
be making any difference at all to the
uh to the government there well i think
the issue is that
i tweeted we are watching the the most
dramatic de-radicalization of the left
we have ever seen
in you know in history because they're
just doing what they're supposed to do
they're just doing what they're told
annoying notifications uh well so many
of these prominent leftists were
anti-fbi anti-cia anti-government
pro-freedom pro-free speech
anti-big pharma anti-monsanto now all of
a sudden all a whole bunch of these
leftists that i know anarchists
you know or
they were right are cheering on massive
you know multinational corporations and
the government and and also doing what
they're told all the time like saying
you know we're all supposed to get the
vaccine because we're told to do it
we're all supposed to wear face masks
because we're told to do it we're not
supposed to see our friends
uh we're not supposed to do anything it
is sort of fascinating to see
anti-authoritarians
succumbing to this culture of fear like
when you're cast overboard and you're
drowning it doesn't matter whose flag is
painted on the lifeboat that comes up
that's not what i'm talking about they
basically are afraid for their lives no
no no they think their best chance no
i'm talking about people who are
gleefully gloating and cheering on the
fbi even though they're like antifa i i
i have a bunch of people i know who are
antifa on facebook that i've because i i
was downright by wall street i've i have
thousands of friends who are leftists on
facebook and thousands who are right and
i see the leftist posting like yeah fbi
and i'm like
aren't you the guy for the giuliani
stuff oh yeah and i'm like aren't you
the people who hated the fbi and thought
that the warrantless spying and all this
crazy stuff the government was doing was
bad and they're like well i mean it's
good to see justice finally and i'm like
so you were never actually about
curtailing government authority it was
just i like power when it's for me i
think we are seeing a lot of that did
you see that cia that that like super
woke up
yeah yeah super creepy that was so crazy
it's a it's a it's a commercial for the
cia and it's only like i'm a cisgendered
you know
intersectional intersectional woman of
color with generalized anxiety disorder
right and i am working for the cia wow
yeah it was a commercial to like go work
for the cio yeah yeah yeah it was about
how yeah even if you're not a white
person you can go work for the cia
but that wasn't really
that wasn't really the message that came
across instead it just looked like the
cia is a massively dysfunctional
organization with a lot of naval gazing
and ego trips yeah that sounds about
right yeah yeah maybe that is what it is
don't see the cia headquarters it looks
like the starship enterprise the bridge
or the starship doesn't work they have
it built so like it's like a captain's
chair in the middle wow they talk about
ego yeah that does sound pretty i mean
look hold on hold on hold on a minute
that's a legend ian if i had a
government budget that was like in the
trillions of dollars
i'm giving myself the card chair dude
it's a pretty cool chair yeah so i'd
have the whole thing dwarf behind me the
next generation next generation is your
favorite yeah i've been i've been just
watching it it's on the bbc every day
right around the right time oh it's on
netflix all of them oh yeah yeah and
before that i had japanese bootlegs of
the whole seven seasons
uh
people don't like voyager i like voyager
i like uh you know d space nine is
really good deep space nine i think
avery brooks is just an amazing captain
i haven't watched any of the new ones
though no i haven't it could be the nsa
that has that oh i did get sucked into
the original series though during the uh
during the pandemic that one i haven't
watched you know it's great and it's
super campy it's really a lot of fun
yeah like guys season one of the next
generation was kinda yeah beard right
right but going back to the main point
we are we are witnessing this massive uh
de-radicalization and so we're talking
about the curfew in in montreal
the reason why these products don't work
is because the organized activist left
that actually pressures the government
typically and usually wins like in the
united states they're they don't care
about this they're in favor of locking
down well we saw that early in the
pandemic i think it was like april 21st
or something like that there was a big
protest of some anti-lockdown people in
michigan and they you know stormed the
capital in michigan they stormed lansing
and were denounced as horrible grandma
killers and white supremacists and
racists
right these terrible terrible people who
just wanted to go to the coffee shop and
get their hair done and things uh of
course it's just evil to want to leave
your house so they were just
you know
really thrown under the bus media
denounced them everyone said they were
terrible
and it was you know a month and a couple
of days later
when all of a sudden you had massive
protests and those were okay
so the lockdown protests
that was a problem wanting to get your
life back wanting to reopen your
business that meant you were a super bad
person and should probably you know be
completely threatened and deplatformed
but then if you're protesting
racism you get a full pass this this is
why i think conservatives at this point
are really dumb for continuing to
support cops we had that people don't
think conservatives should support cops
absolutely not what do you think they
should do instead they should protest
cops and call for their abolition
we we have conservatives should call for
police police abolitionists yes 100 with
like ilhan omar absolutely 100 i am
dying to hear why oh yeah absolutely um
before the elections and before the
coveted lockdowns there's a good reason
to want to have police i mean crime's
been skyrocketing across you know a
bunch of different cities since police
have been defunded and demoralized
however after the elections and i've
said this many times when that when the
voters rejected the position that cops
are good and voted for those who oppose
the police
well at that point i say first
if you're a cop staying in this
political environment where they're
gonna lock you up they're gonna put you
in jail well then i'm not gonna defend
you when that time comes because you
decided to stay in the burning building
perhaps you said i'm gonna stay in to
try and save lives okay i can respect
that still i warned you and said get out
while you still can you know the fire
was was coming
what we're seeing now with coven the
police gleefully
sight gave tickets to the jewish
community harassed jews and synagogues
uh padlocked uh uh
gates shut so that you know little fish
couldn't play in playgrounds they they
as you mentioned they weren't enforcing
in new york at that bar owner but the
state police did come and barricade so
cops at this point cops are cops
many conservatives actually started
smack talking police we saw a ton of
conservative commentators saying that
the cops turned their back on on the
good hard-working small business and
started arresting and fining people and
ticketing people and harassing them just
because they were told to we see the
cops guarding the illegal black lives
matter mural in new york city bill de
blasio had no authorization to
appropriate funds to do that yeah he did
that and 27 cops arrested stood guard
and arrested those who challenged the
illegal actions of the mayor how could
you as a conservative who likely not not
every single person many who don't live
in the big cities defend corrupt
democrat politicians and the police
forces that are enabling them to keep
doing the illegal things they're doing
like painting big black lives matter
murals and arresting small business
owners and families and shutting down
churches but what police do
is what the executive branch tells them
to do that's their job so the police
aren't there to have their own
independent opinion
the police say did bill de blasio break
the law
did bill de blasio break the law in
appropriating taxpayer dollars to paint
them to paint that big black lives
matter mural in front of the trump tower
just to be a jerk right he did um
yeah he did not have a permit so that
means that the police officers are
hating and abetting a crime theft of
taxpayer dollars
i'm sorry i don't care if you're a cop
you break the law you break the law so
you think they should have gone up there
and arrested bill de blasio that's
perhaps true
that doesn't least that should have
changed they will not stand guard in an
illegal street mural right they probably
shouldn't have done that but they also
you want to primarily have to do what
they're told
or they can't
look that's what they do so i think the
mayor told the cop to rob a bank and the
cop did it he should go to prison well
sure yeah if if the mayor steals public
funds
to paint the street and then tells the
gops to guard his illicit work right the
cops are breaking the law yeah but i
also don't think that destroying the
institution of law enforcement is going
to do anything to to make anything
better no matter if you see what you
have in uh in portland which there's a
video andy portland is a disaster well
so so look there's there's uh a guy i
don't know who he is i don't know maybe
he did something all i see is this one
video and based on this one video
we see antifa
marching towards a guy who's backing up
with a baseball bat saying get away i'm
warning you okay get away i'll come back
i'll f you up get away from me the cops
immediately arrest him and apologize to
antifa
well portland is a mess too but so why
why why are conservatives defending cops
who are doing that are they defending
cops who are doing that or are they
defending the institution of police work
so what do we what do we have right now
in terms of these big cities
with
cops who have been shutting down
churches who have been defending the
corrupt politicians and arresting anyone
like portland i understand is a mess
right
so okay how about this we'll get some
we'll get specific abolish the portland
police department
well the mayor i think is in charge of
the portland police department and i
think so
yeah so probably they should get rid of
that mayor and get a mayor who knows
what he's doing
i i think the responsibilities of the
individual
the individual police officers sure and
they are leaving the forces in droves
and they're going places where i think
christie noam put out a thing saying
like we're hiring police officers um i
think there's some hiring going on in
dallas you know these officers who are
leaving these big blue cities are
finding work elsewhere and i think it
makes sense for them to do that but i
don't think that it makes sense to
completely
say that you know law enforcement itself
should be abolished in florida
you can own guns
sure in west virginia guns wyoming guns
texas interestingly texas has some
pretty serious laws but in new york you
can own illegal guns
without any real impunity in chicago uh
you basically can't in maryland and new
jersey you basically can't you can own
long guns handguns they just have insane
restrictions and it's the police that
are going to be the ones who take away
your constitutional right
so well they're going to enforce it
they're going to enforce that law
yeah if a law passes it'd be
unconstitutional for sure so why would a
cop who sworn off the constitution say
well you know my corrupt boss told me to
arrest you so you're under arrest are
cops sworn to protect the constitution i
thought that was the judiciary that's it
police the police were not the
constitution really yes they do that's
interesting and they don't uphold it so
i think about red states well they don't
they uphold the law right and then if
the law is challenged they would uphold
the law that was remade there there's
interesting arguments i understand uh i
i think we need police but here's what
i'm saying maybe we should say abolish
blue state police you look at the red
states that have been doing a really
good job with covid not arresting people
for running their businesses allowing
things to remain open and and tactfully
and guarant a lot of constitutional
carry laws being passed so now i think
it's like iowa or utah whatever uh taxes
is about to pass it as well yeah i saw
that uh west virginia already has it i
look at these red states and i'm like
the cops they're doing a fantastic job
and they've got and there's better
leadership not perfect and you look at
these blue states and the cops are
enforcing the most insane interpretation
defending antifa they're not being
prosecuted you if you accidentally cross
the bridge from philly into new jersey
with a handgun that's a fail then you're
really in trouble and why and a cop
would actually lock you up for this but
don't you think that's a question of
leadership i mean the police are
the police are there to
they basically do what they're told
that's bad yeah well that's just doing
what it is that's really really bad i'm
not saying that's good or bad i'm saying
that is their function that's the same
thing is the true with the you know with
the military do we want a situation
right and so here's the question do you
want a situation where the enforcement
branch of the executive arm of
government
is going against that executive arm of
government do we want that branch of
government to just be split in half like
that do we want law enforcement saying
uh i know that you're supposed to tell
me what to do and that's your job and my
job is to do what i'm told and we're not
going to do that anymore do we want the
army to stand up to the president and
say we're not going to do what you tell
us yes we we want that we absolutely do
yeah if the president said do something
illegal and that we it's actually by law
they have to say no isn't that where we
start landing into like uh you know
military coup type of situation
i think that's i think that's a
dangerous thing well if the president
gives an illegal order
there by by law they have to say no
the police sworn off the constitution
and still are willing to uphold i think
this is a connectivity yeah i mean i
think it's a real problem to say that
we want the police force to stand up on
its own hind legs and
you know start marching around the farm
yard and telling the other animals
stretch to say that versus cops should
reject illegal orders
probably they should reject illegal
orders but you know why should i support
them i don't know i don't know i mean
listen i live in brooklyn new york and
if we don't have police officers
we're going to have an even worse
situation than we have now but didn't
you already say the cops are nowhere to
be seen and they're not i don't see them
i don't see them around they're not
enforcing covet orders so it sounds like
they're doing good i'm happy that
they're not enforcing that they're not
well i should say not enforcing the
unconstitutional things
i i guess the issue i have right now is
it seems like a lot of the arguments for
police are coming from urban
conservatives which are few and far
between relative to rural conservatives
right there's like five of us and we
have dinner a couple times so yeah for
me i'm kind of like we don't have cops
out here
but i'm allowed to have you know to an
extent weapons because we're actually in
maryland we're on the border so uh in
west virginia you can literally walk
around with a barrett you know
m82 if you want to it's really heavy and
probably ridiculous but you could and i
wonder why it is that in these you know
i wouldn't call them
dense
but they're they're they're communities
that have you have next door neighbors
like literally 10 feet from your house
just like any other urban community why
is there why is there no won't be
breaking in anybody's houses and there's
no cops and why is it that new york city
you've got democrats these activists
complaining about the cops but it's the
few it's the 20 of new york that's
conservative defending them meanwhile
also getting abused by them but i just
don't see any legitimate arguments the
democrats in new york city who are
calling for
getting rid of police
they don't actually mean what they're
saying right like the park slope
democrats don't mean
uh you know get the police out of park
slope they don't mean that at all
they mean they say it
what are they saying they say like
defund police well then but that's not
what they can't read their minds yeah no
we can't read their minds but you know
what they're saying they're saying
police are racist and get them out of
the black communities um and then the
police leave the black communities and
crime goes up and more more people get
killed but we shouldn't assume that you
know
when we see people in this community
saying get the cops out of here i think
we should say okay that's your community
not mine
yeah but that's because you live out
here and i'm like i'm from the south
side of chicago
so i'd love to have in the south south
side of chicago been able to bear arms
to defend myself from the gang violence
instead after getting shot at i'm like i
probably shouldn't live here anymore
because well because you can't really
have a gun there but you know the gang
members can because you know because
they get them illegally right
this is kind of what i was saying but
the cops would arrest me if i tried to
do anything about it in new york city we
had giuliani who came in and really
started trying to clean up the city in
what like 92. and i remember it very
distinctly because it got a lot harder
to buy drugs in washington square park
we had to like
go down the lower east side to do that
um and we you know we made it work we
figured out a workaround but uh so
giuliani really did an awful lot to
clamp down on crime in the city
manhattan got a lot safer
um and it was actually pretty remarkable
and then when julian um bloomberg came
in he took
this gift of a really safe manhattan and
he used that to create basically a
playground for the wealthy and then
bolster the outer boroughs so the outer
boroughs got a lot safer too he got
slammed for this you know broken windows
policing thing but that was actually
rather effective policy and the entire
city got drastically more safe it's just
too authoritarian for me well it was
actually i mean it was pretty magical to
be able to like walk around manhattan at
four o'clock in the morning with
absolutely no fear for your safety what
a year and two months ago did they have
guns banned back then
i really don't know i never had to i've
i never looked into owning a gun in new
york city until maybe like a month or so
ago do you ever hear the story about the
uh the black cop who started giving out
tickets in central park
no i could be getting the story wrong
but it was basically uh black cop shows
up in central park handing out tickets
to couples sitting down in a picnic with
wine public public drinking is a is a
petty offense here's your your fine your
summons or whatever
well the reason he did it i guess was
because the cops would go to the black
neighborhood start giving out tickets to
people drinking 40s on their stew sure
so he said you want to come to my
neighborhood i'm going to go to central
park and do the same thing the cop got
in trouble got reprimanded so
these these these big cities that have
been been run by democrats for for
generations
have these problems with asymmetrical
enforcement and i think it's poverty is
a big component of it less so race but i
do think race plays a role why should i
defend these cops when the democrats are
the ones complaining about them and
they're willing to enforce
unconstitutional laws and i don't live
there so sure 20 of the people who live
there are conservative and defending
cops meanwhile they're the ones being
locked down by the cops and the cops are
defending anti-fun protecting them or at
the very least when they do arrest them
the da's cut them loose then when a
conservative gets arrested they get the
book thrown at them the cops are willing
to say i'm being neutral by arresting
the both of you and the d.a says good
job auntie foy you're free to go
conservative welcome to jail i don't
know the protest that i went to um
this year in union square and around new
york city
i saw maybe like
a couple of times somebody got arrested
and usually it was one of the protesters
and most of the time what i saw were
cops you know the protesters would come
up to them and say you guys are pigs and
all of this stuff and the cops would
just applaud them and say oh you're so
brave so courageous and so brave um no
they were they were making fun of them
right right but you remember when the
cops kept a knee for the for the
protesters yes i do remember that that's
really good for conservatives that
happened in brooklyn i thought that was
a horror show in fact and i i don't i
don't see yourself in opposition to that
in fact yeah so so i think conservatives
are unwilling to stand up for themselves
and that's part of the problem i think
this is a very dangerous game though i
think defunding police no matter what
side you're on saying that we do not
need
uh law
enforcement have you tried to buy a gun
in new york city well like it's like
several weeks you need an interview you
need to give them a reason why you need
to buy a gun you can't you've got an
authoritarianism problem well that is an
authoritarian problem yeah yeah i agree
so but i think that it's a you know it's
a dangerous right
i hear what you're saying about you know
police not upholding their duty i think
it's a very dangerous road to go down to
say that we don't need police at all
because they are ineffectual again it's
a it's it's
it's destroying something without
building anything in its place i'm not
saying i i do build a framework first
yeah i do the problem is when what's
happening is that cops will without
hesitation arrest moderates and
conservatives or even some in some
instances as liberals especially if
they're upholding their second amendment
rights in a city with skyrocketing gun
violence and crime i'm like well that's
kind of a problem then because they
can't keep a control they can't keep
control of the crime but they're
absolutely willing to arrest law-abiding
citizens who get scared and want to buy
something to defend themselves i'll
check that out i haven't seen those
cases and i'll take a look at dalton
people getting arrested for having guns
people getting arrested in new york for
having that was all the time
illegal guns for having yeah because
they're all illegal well they're not all
illegal like you you you're just getting
into this or my house if you go to the
cvs near my house you can hear a lot of
gunfire it's kind of jarring so it's
downstairs illegal illegal guns are what
people have in places like new york
because you need a qualifying reason to
actually get a gun right but illegal
guns are also what are shooting little
babies at barbecues in the middle of bed
stuy yeah because criminals commit
crimes right the cops can they yeah i
mean there should be i think better gun
laws in new york once i looked into it i
was actually really shocked to find how
difficult it would be
to get any kind of weapon so less gun
laws
i think the i think the gun laws should
not be quite so strict at all i think
most conservatives don't live in big
cities that are run by democrats
and i think it's silly to support
the broken and unconstitutional systems
propped up by democrats when you don't
live there and then just
it makes no sense to me at this point
now before the election i was absolutely
like yeah these people are crazy do you
found the police as nuts and then when
the people in these cities all voted to
defund their police and support
democrats i'm like that's insane too i
certainly didn't vote to defund the
police did you see what happened in
minneapolis that went really badly
they defunded police seattle defunded
police they voted for it they voted for
it and so the people should if look i
lived in new york for like five or six
years
and there were serious problems with
crime and uh i lived on the street where
the two cops got executed by the black
nationalists yeah i remember that so i
was like um you know gonna leave so i
moved over i jumped i jumped the river
the jersey side and then someone planted
bombs in manhattan and in jersey city
and i was like i'm gonna move maybe away
from these cities they can't stop the
violence and the crime right but they
also but they can stop you from
defending yourself as a law abiding
citizen they can stop you from getting a
gun because they have really harsh gun
control laws that don't work yeah that
don't actually keep illegal guns off the
street and who's enforcing that
oh i the police i'm sure it's the police
absolutely but i don't think it makes
sense to
take it away without building something
in its place we can't have a situation
where there's no police in new york city
that's just a that's just a horrifying
idea
but already we're looking at it right
we're looking at so we had votes to
defund the police i think bloomberg took
a bunch of money away from police and
gave it to prostitutes or something like
that i mean something really stupid um
social workers are supposed to show up
now at calls or whatever else but i
don't think that we can just destroy it
and take it away if there's nothing in
its place we've already seen
so much violent crime increase and a lot
of that is because the police have been
you know pushed aside and dropped away i
think if you talk the police talk to the
police commissioner at this point
um you know he's not in favor of any of
this stuff either so
sure like are the police doing a bad job
yes does that mean we need to get rid of
the police no
it also doesn't mean we need to reform
them in the way that the leftists are
saying we need to reform them because
that's not effective either
i think people need we need to bring
back individual responsibility well
i totally agree with individual
responsibilities i don't think it makes
sense to be like we should have more
cops arresting more people so i can feel
safe even though i'm not allowed to have
a gun no i'm not saying there should be
more cops arresting more people well
that broken window policing is where
they use the harshest enforcement
tactics on the lowest level crime but
what they do when they
when they were doing the broken windows
thing what they were doing is they were
finding illegal guns that's how that
that's how that worked when they were
arresting you know turn style jumpers
which i don't think you should be
arresting turn style jumpers necessarily
what makes the guns illegal
what makes the guns illegal is that they
don't have a permit to carry them
the constitution says you can
okay so what do you want to do about it
you want to just get rid of police and
let the cities burn is that what you're
like what is your proposal
to replace the police so if there's no
police
right let's say let's say the thing goes
forward let's say the leftists defund
all the police and the conservatives
stop supporting police and then all the
police are just like ah this job is
horrifying i'm gonna quit and go do
something else then what happens right
what happens to the cities and
what is supposed to take the place of
the police are we just not supposed to
have any enforcement at all what's the
point of having any laws once we take
away the police you still have courts
okay so you if there's no one to arrest
anybody then there's no reason to have a
court if there's no one to enforce the
laws if there's no one to enforce a law
then why do we have any laws why is that
only some laws are being enforced and
some aren't and why is it that it's
favorable to the left i don't know that
it is in all cases but i don't think
you're proposing a solution i think that
you're just jumping on board saying like
you know these guys are doing a bad job
anyway so let's just get rid of them get
a solution buy a gun so the solution for
all crime is that we should all just be
armed yes
you can defend yourself if you're armed
what if you what if you have no hands
how are you supposed to when are you
supposed to do that that's like that's
not a real argument though but it kind
of is how is a person with no hands
wants to defend themselves period with
their feet i guess well but the police
would protect a person with no hands
ideally
private security so let's say you're
poor
you can't afford private security and
you don't have your hands to hold a gun
i mean this sounds cops are arresting
people simply for having illegal guns
but the guns can't be illegal under the
constitution anyway so it sounds like
what happened is new york passed a bunch
of unconstitutional laws they're using
to arrest innocent people perhaps that's
true but they're not only arresting
people for having guns broken windows
policing resulted in
the policy idea was that if you arrest
people for the lowest level crimes like
jaywalking you will actually deal with
higher level crimes so they would arrest
someone for jaywalking and it's
extremely disruptive to someone's life i
don't think you're getting arrested for
jaywalking first of all
um i think you're getting arrested for
other things probably not james yeah
that was the idea of broken windows
policing yeah when you see that if you
have somebody you know if you have
people committing lower level crimes
right so why don't we look at the data
so under bloomberg you had this
situation you had
uh you know you had stop and frisk which
of course was extremely racist because
it was only done in black and brown
communities because it was only done in
the most poor communities um
so you have that and then you have you
know the broken windows thing how did we
get to a point where new york was so
safe how did we get to a point where new
york was the safest city in the country
it wasn't just authoritarianism
there was a deep there was a decrease in
crime and most people were able to live
freely on all levels of society and what
was what was the
cause of that decrease in crime well
that's what i'm asking so there's a
bunch of different theories on it the
most interesting i think is actually the
removal of lead from gasoline the
removal of lead from gasoline actually
correlates very closely to a decrease in
crime in like the 2010s i think this was
like in the 70s or 80s okay because i'm
talking about i mean it was in the last
within like the last 20 years that new
york basically was disneyland i don't
think that the lead thing is the perfect
example but
pollutants in the air was causing people
to have problems so they say uh the
other issue is that general prosperity
in the u.s and economic economic
expansion reduced the amount of crime in
general across the board sure it did
cell phones are one of the the biggest
uh um
one of the biggest reasons why there's
less murder historically in a certain
period from like to like around the late
2000s into 2010s was because people were
still trying to kill you but now you
could call 9-1-1 the moment it happened
substantially decreasing the likelihood
of death so why is there starters
so why is there so much more crime now
that we have pulled back on police
there's a lot of reasons for it uh one
is probably the defunding of police for
sure then there's also
covid desperation anger rage people
being locked up in their homes
an increase in uh poverty probably was a
substantial component to an increase in
crime so was there an increase in
poverty in new york city well people
didn't have jobs people a lot of people
lost a lot of people just shut down so a
bunch of people left new york city
entirely rich people though yeah like
400 000 rich families so poor people
less or lower middle class or middle
class who lost their jobs and now we're
reliant on these stimulus payments which
weren't particularly well they weren't
really enough money yeah so then people
become angry and desperate not to
mention that there's no one really on
the streets so it was it was interesting
because initially there was a decrease
in crime simply because of a decrease
because there was no one there but then
yeah the emptiness opportunity the
emptiness creates more crime so i think
so what should happen so your vision for
new york city is that there's no police
at all and just everyone's walking
around with a gun well uh before the
election i would have said having a
police department for sure but i think
the problem now is you have a bunch of
gluttonous city dwellers who are just
accepting of the big hand of government
to do everything for them instead of
taking responsibility for the fact that
you have problems in your city people
say just let the government do it you
know just have like the police should do
it even when the police will uphold
unconstitutional laws
but most importantly this stems from
watching the police oppress
people going to church
people going to synagogues all of that
stuff was completely wrong but i don't
think i i still just don't think that i
was thinking away authoritarianism for
the sake of feeling safe sorry i would
give up i don't i don't think taking
away law enforcement is actually going
to create a safer city those who would
give up freedom in exchange for security
deserve neither and will lose both
yeah but in a city
where you have so many people living
close to each other pretty sure ben
franklin within the city yeah but
philadelphia in 1776 was nothing like
new york city in 2021 i don't think that
that's a justification for
disregarding the constitution no perhaps
not but i also don't think that entirely
police are
i don't know what all these cases are i
mean are you talking just specifically
about guns because i'm talking about
first and foremost they shut down
churches right in violation of the first
amendment and
and that went to the supreme court and
it was overturned and then cuomo
immediately said don't care i'll do
another one and did it again right but
it was overturned in the supreme court
except cuomo ignored it and just signed
another executive order de blasio did it
again but the churches are open in new
york city eventually sure they're not
not immediately no will the diocese had
to decide and the communities had to
decide for themselves that they were
going to do it themselves while the
churches were shut down the city allowed
black lives matter to protest without
massachusetts yes and that was insanity
but that's not a reason to take away law
enforcement when they're the ones
enforcing
a an an a corrupt political system and
absolving themselves of responsibility i
actually think it is i think in a lot of
cases you had the churches themselves
staying closed after the order which i
don't think was reasonable either the
the cops spying on children at jewish
schools the the video where the cop goes
into uh acidic uh a jewish man's eatery
that was closed simply because he
prompted the doctor
i don't think that's okay either but
what i don't think you're providing is
any kind of reasonable
solution to it i am yeah it's called
personal responsibility you're saying
that everyone should just be walking
around with a gun absolutely yeah in new
york city yep
well i think that's not a great you're
responsible for what comes out of that
gun you're responsible for your own
safety stop enforcing unconstitutional
edict enforcement simply because you
don't want to be responsible for
yourself i don't think that walking
around with a gun is necessarily the way
that everyone would choose to be
responsible for themselves and i think
there are a lot of people where walking
around with a gun is not a responsible
move at all if you were if you if if you
were in new york city and a guy came up
to with a gun is a cop gonna jump out
from the woodwork and save you no so
what do you do
i don't know probably get shot so does
that doesn't sound like you have a real
solution for you know how to deal with
crime but like if i was walking around
with a gun and someone popped out and
had a gun i would probably still get
shot actually in
so so it's not always going to work for
everybody so why why is it in west
virginia you can have these big
communities and there's no police
department but people aren't breaking
into every single building and getting
bugged in the street people aren't
breaking into every single building
getting mugged in the street all the
time in new york
crime is skyrocketing in new york city
violent crime violent crime yeah why is
it
i'm not sure why it is exactly so i
think i mean i think we had police pull
back an awful lot i think that was bad i
think we had you know the covert
restrictions were pretty bad as well but
i don't
you know
i just i'm not seeing your solution as
very viable i think it's it's not so
much of a solution being viable it's how
much how much do you reject the
constitution on the principles of
modernity i think we have to fight them
in ways that are not just necessarily
like from our hip
we have systems in place we have a
government system in place for a reason
and i think that it can be pretty
effective we have to elect better
leaders for sure that's a problem this
is why conservatives get crushed
repeatedly why because we're not willing
to just walk around with guns and shoot
everybody well because they're they're
deferential to the left in every respect
i don't think this is different
absolutely i think i think it's
deference to the social order and i
think it's deference to you know the
three branches of government and the
checks and balances on those the cops
have been maligned and the ones who stay
on the job are dropping to their knees
and groveling
the people in the city have been
disarmed and the ones who are refusing
to defend themselves are dropping to
their knees and groveling the mayor
illegally appropriated tax funds to
paint a political message in front of a
building and the police defended it and
the people of the city who stay there
are dropping to their knees and
groveling i don't think that's true in
most of the cases it's just apathy it's
it's a disregard for what this country
was built upon the founding principles
what it means to be responsible for
yourself it is saying i understand the
democrats passed unconstitutional laws
the cops shouldn't force it anyway
because i'm not responsible so what do
you think of the whole fourth turning
concept do you think that's where we are
do you think we're in that last
that last area where it's just like
everybody's completely weak and
ineffectual and then we're gonna have
something really bad happen to create
more stronger like strong people who
then take charge i mean
what are we looking at like we have like
a pretty stark disagreement here with
regard to the social order i mean you
seem to think it's in a much worse place
than i do which honestly like you know
perhaps i'm a little optimistic that's
something
that's something that nobody would have
ever accused me of ever in my life
previously did you did you watch the
chauvin trial
no i did not watch the chauvin trial i
watched the chauvin trial and i heard
the prosecution's own witness argue that
chauvin used a lesser force option
mm-hmm we we're now hearing reports i
haven't verified these that one of the
jurors was previously a policy matter
the judicial system is corrupted by
spineless and feckless judges
and court officers who don't want to
face any repercussions some of the
jurors the one juror who came out and
said she was an alternate that i was
scared i didn't want to go through the
road yeah i write about that as well
these these are people who are willing
to give up all of their freedoms in
exchange for security what what we are
watching is that
justice is being crushed
kyle written house will likely get life
in prison for defending himself you can
watch a 78 year old man get bashed in
the back of the head by antifa but
heaven forbid you actually want to
defend your community and then what
happens is conservatives still keep
coming out and groveling before the left
i don't think they're traveling before
the left i don't think that's what's
going on i think they're supporting
you know a democratic system of
government which is worth supporting so
you're playing a game that's the other
side is cheating over and over again
threatening to flip the board and hit
everybody and the conservatives keep
going okay okay and i don't mean all
conservatives right especially mean the
republican party and and and the people
the conservatives who remain in these
cities who are defending a broken system
yes we're all conservatives
so what's supposed to happen are we just
supposed to say like okay the social
order is completely destroyed let's just
blow it up and then see what happens
i think
you have an apocalyptic view of what
happens when people take responsibility
for themselves i don't think so i don't
think i do i think people taking
responsibility for themselves and
completely destroying and dismantling
the government structure are two
completely different destroy the
government structure you're saying take
away law enforcement if we take away law
enforcement there's no point in having
any laws well the people who voted for
it
what people like people in these urban
metros keep voting for the politicians
calling for defunding or abolishing
police conal harris literally fundraised
for the writers yes i know they then
they lie about it happening and then
conservatives are like well let him keep
doing it so 75 million people did not
vote for this for this administration
but those people don't live in cities
mostly well some of them do some of them
sure right but 75 million people did not
vote for this administration the
administration won anyway it's it's
running roughshod over them anyway
you know and you have the corporations
and the social media giants taking their
voices away anyway and crushing them
anyway so what is your so you're just
saying like everyone should what move to
the middle of nowhere and carry a gun
around i mean you can get out of the
cities is a good start a lot of
conservatives have been repeating but
why should we have to you know change
our lifestyle fully
what if we like living in cities what if
we like you know having this view it's
not necessarily the world change for you
instead
you know we built these beautiful
palaces these beautiful cities so that
we could live in them so that we could
go to the theater whenever we wanted so
we could go to museums so that we could
meet up in parks and see our friends and
do all kinds of things and there's
nothing wrong with a city lifestyle you
know we don't all want to grow grow
gardens and
and have chickens and things we we don't
all want to do that we don't want to
carry guns around either and there's
nothing wrong with that and you can take
away someone else's right to do those
things even in a city which they do you
can't have chickens in many of these
cities listen i totally i totally
disagree with the gun laws in new york
city watch it there you can have
chickens too harsh and there are people
who have chickens in brooklyn
so and gardens and whatever else many
urban metros ban livestock okay why well
so vote against it move to a city and go
vote against it if you don't so that's
what i said before the election i was
very much in favor of supporting the
police once we realized that after all
the riots and all the small businesses
being harassed and churches being shut
down people voted for this
now the responsible thing to do is to
recognize you've lost that argument and
if you want to live in a city where you
have no rights by all means you're free
to do so but it's clear that new york is
supporting unconstitutional laws the
police allow black lives matter to march
without masks on repeatedly over and
over and over again in many major urban
metros and then when a conservative
comes out in the police aren't enforcing
masks in new york city anyway no but
they're shutting churches down and
making sure small businesses can't serve
drinks they're not doing that anymore
but right they were doing that and i
disagree with all of that throughout and
i i spoke and wrote against all of that
when it happens to you again like am i
supposed to be like oh no the poor
conservatives getting arrested again no
i mean you can do whatever you want out
here and people can do what they want in
their cities now i'll clarify there's
like urban conservatives who are
remaining and watching all this happen
and i'm hearing more and more from
most conservatives who agree the city's
vote to get rid of the police let them
have it if you want to stay and live in
that then that's your choice well i
guess we'll see what happens we got to
do super chats okay and see what the
users have to think because we
definitely went long so if you haven't
already go to timcast.com become a
member smash that like button and now
we're going to read super chats because
uh i took two we i went way too long
all right
jordan jones says your first beer in may
is on me ian there you go buddy
john lee says hey tim you sound sick
today in your videos your voice was
cracking and stuff so i hope you feel
better if you are sick also any update
on chicken city it is
operating we do need to get a chicken
whisperer out here and get the camera
set up and it's not that i'm sick it's
just allergies are brutal man eat a big
scoop of coconut oil coconut oil what is
that gonna do you feel good oil up your
throat
all right let's see flimsy fox says
hi tim i want to say thank you for all
you do your informative videos kept me
from voting for a particular
presidential candidate i would have
regretted i think we all know which one
i think many of the leftists also regret
that decision as well and the neolib
democrat voter types have kind of just
stopped paying attention
the median says i didn't realize how
narcissistic leftists are till one
killed my dnd group worst they claimed i
was not tolerant of their beliefs as
they blew up when i mentioned facts and
asked asked questions wish me luck in
finding a new dnd group
good luck good luck we're gonna start
doing dnd role initiative nice lucas
paradise has watched mortal kombat cole
young is from the south side of chicago
his wife's name is allison and obviously
asian are the writers tim cast fanboys
yes they are mortal kombat is this
generation citizen kane fight me that's
a joke i don't mean it youtube calm down
mav says according to new uh to the new
yorker senator harry reid was blocked
from
accessing ufo debris held by lockheed
martin a senator blocked by the pentagon
from accessing ufo debris when are
people going to wake up to this story
you know i think a lot of this stuff is
uh
maybe they're just trying to make you
think there's something out there
because it's like a psyop for like
foreign war or something you know make
the enemy think we have access to
technologies they don't freak them out
also didn't someone say it was birds
yeah i think like a lot of these ufos
were actually just birds interesting
just blurry birds and ir cameras oh
blurry birds
i love that daft punk song about it
what is it when he's like uh i don't
know there's something out there
it's moving in a
well
earth boundary commemoration have you
ever seen that when all the birds fly in
one giant bird it looks like yeah that's
cool when that happens oh really you
don't say says did you did you see you
showed up in the project veritas
oligarchy music video
yes i did
yeah did you see the music video i
didn't i had to go watch it i didn't see
you i saw your name yeah there's like a
little tv pops up and i'm and it's from
the show and i'm like you know the new
york times just tripping over themselves
like yeah it's funny
it was great yeah james got moves it's
nice
it's like an 80s music video he's got
the sledgehammer
all right oddball gaming says hey tim
this is why the tornado that went over
you fired up again in frederick's
maryland even illinois had a tornado
spotted traveling east target areas
tonight in arkansas missouri and couple
dixie alley states did it happen all
over a lot of storms interesting yeah it
moved right over us
it was headed straight to us
yeah though it was actually kind of cool
with all the leaves blowing over i love
this weather
zekniks says defunding the police will
lead to the expulsion of local law
enforcement creating a power vacuum for
some sort of federal police to come in
to save the day this is the goal of
defund the police i hear this a lot and
it doesn't make any sense
that's what happened in camden though
then the stadis came in the state police
came in yeah but they're saying federal
federalization of the police right like
in new york the state police came in
when the local cops wouldn't
force in staten island they had
jurisdiction yeah did you know that
staten island once seceded i'm sorry
voted to secede from new york oh they
should have done it well i guess the
state said no
i was i don't know i saw it on reddit i
don't know if it's true or not
if it's on reddit it must be true i
guess i want to look that up now
aiden says hey tim high schooler from
the last gop collar county in chicago
here i have been interning with local
campaigns my psych teacher started
preaching critical race theory and told
us to read d'angelo and kendy how am i
meant to fight this
uh
you know what i would do
i would go back and i would ask why i
was told to read a a book from a
self-avowed racist that's a good
question robin deangelo's self about
racist and then they'll ask for proof
and then show them proof there's a lot
of proof cause they probably didn't read
it but she says she's racist yeah so she
says she can't be cured of racism yeah
it's a it's just a way to keep people
oppressed in their own mindset and
incapable of taking personal
responsibility
it's awesome
you know what i would do is i would i
would read the books and then i would
read books that are contrary to it and i
would i would write a thesis about why
the books were wrong that's what i would
do
i would read olinsky's rules for
radicals and then apply the principles
in this setting so make this teacher
live up to their own rules i assume your
teacher is white in which case you
should say after reading the book i
realized you're oppressing us
and i want to know how you're going to
make it up to the class because
deangelo says she's a racist you're you
know you're with his teacher
i'm assuming it's white maybe they're
not i don't know maybe i shouldn't
assume that sort of doesn't matter what
color they are it's still oppressive to
make people read about how they're
racist i just assume they're white
because most of these people are like
the critical race theorists tend to be
like progressive white suburbanites yeah
so virtue signalling yeah use it olinsis
rules for radicals
all right rob lowe robs lowe's says side
note i watched your recent cast castle
and i sent you an email i thought it
would be a great episode if you are
interested in making a range on the
property if legally allowed i do not
know how to i do know how to operate
heavy equipment not here in maryland but
we do have a property in west virginia
we're going to be filming at at some
point
so
west virginia is freedom
eli m says tim today crowder mentioned
your west virginia skatepark will you
invite him on your show crowder crowder
is always invited to come on the show
it's just that he runs his own show so
like when would he come
you know we've talked it's just
like
i've been on his show
we do everything in person here
i don't make exceptions you know like
we've had a lot of really awesome guests
be like can we do skype and i'm like
no no
the reality is we just we don't have any
monitor set up for anybody so like when
when you guys watching are seeing the
news article no one else can see any of
that and i'm just i don't i don't i
don't like the dynamic of compromising
than doing a digital like over the phone
kind of show i don't want to do that
yeah he should come out with his wife
come out for the weekend or something
i totally respect the uh in studio
aspect
yeah because i like that i hate doing
skype stuff it's really
i always look the wrong place also
they'll eventually build monitors with
cameras in them they may already have
them but there will be like contact with
each other
or the the eyes are weird
yeah
i just you gotta that'll be weird and
fake yeah that's gonna change society
big time jay leibgot says i would love
to see a conversation between you and
lex friedman the juxtaposition of your
energies would make for an interesting
content i almost went on his show we
briefly talked uh he was in the area but
we weren't able to make it work that'd
be cool though he's a smart fella
all right here we go dragon lady says
yep giving 50 bucks just a high five
libby for being a fellow star trek fan
tim too but i already knew he was
there you go hey
making me money for being a fan hey how
about that
balthazar says how cost effective could
a lightning capture device be for the
power grid
right now the problem is we don't know
the
i'm not an electrician but it's like we
don't know the voltage or the amperage
or whatever of a lightning strike so you
can't accurately predict how to contain
it i read about this once i was like why
don't we just harness electricity and
like store it somewhere when you guys
were talking about solar and wind i kept
thinking about lightning and geothermal
like volcanic light unless you're dr
brown right emmett brown yeah yeah he's
into it lightning is too random we'd
have to capture it while it's in orbit
maybe before lightning before it gets
hot yeah if we could just collect the
static charge the other issue is that
charges aren't burst charges like what
do we have that can take a lightning
bolt and just store that energy no we're
not like oh yeah i don't know if
graphing can handle the heat there must
be meta materials that can handle the
heat they could have made like a
superconductor that could
get hit once and then be fully charged
that would be really interesting
it's just so much electricity yeah
waiting to be attacked it's a wild
amount shaker silver says
even if the gop wins 2020 who's in
control traditionalists and populists
that actually oppose to the leftists and
neolibs or the soft liberals and neocons
that just roll over what even is a
conservative i mean conservatives today
are democrats 15 years ago basically
that's how i ended up over here it was a
free speech thing
really
oh wow
yeah i look at uh
you know a conservative today a
conservative from 2000 if that person
came here today they'd be banned from
every platform instantly instantly and
they'd be headline media matters but so
would a democrat
from 2000 i think so
from 2000 i don't i don't know if they'd
be insta-banned maybe not instability
they'd be called alt-right and then
certainly they certainly would be on the
wrong side of things right yeah oh
definitely i mean and anyone from the
90s is just screwed
yeah definitely
brandon mcgregor says don't know if it
would happen even after covid but linus
from linus tech tips occasionally
touches on politics i think you could
have a nuanced conversation on certain
current social and economic issues
perhaps but a lot of people who run
shows you know like that
they don't want to
get into the weeds and get accused of
things
you know
so we we i've started talking to a lot
of people who are like you know pro
skaters musicians like you're you're
really influential wouldn't you want to
come on and we'll just talk about this
you know like you don't got to come on
and put on a moga hat or anything just
like how's it going what's going on with
skateboarding how you feeling what do
you feel about cancel culture and then
express your opinions and they're like
oh dude i don't know man like you know
i'll get fired and all my contracts and
oh man
i can understand some of it like if
you're hired by you know an energy drink
company they don't want you
posting videos about politics they want
you posting videos where you're like
gnarly i'm gonna do a backflip you know
and it's fun and energizes the kids
and also as we move forward don't forget
to smash that like button it really
helps us out
person says america is not getting more
racist the democrats are period no
youtube blocked this comment until i
split democrats really that's weird that
is weird
yeah they're using the media to project
that image too i don't even think
they're more racist than they used to be
it's just loud in your face i think
they're more racist than they used to be
really yeah by a lot
bridget f says ian is god eth to the
moon add a zipline tim we want to end
the zipline and we are all fingers of
god should we build a zipline yeah over
a pool
paxton
paxton harrell says you're wrong on pv
being for the rich i've actually started
a company in utah and we've been running
for over a year now selling solar
significantly cheaper because we don't
rely on the tax credits interesting that
is interesting
i wonder how that works with the tax
credits
how can it be cheaper without the tax
credits i have no idea
maybe there's like requirements for what
you have to like regulations to reach
the tax credits so you can actually make
a cheaper product yeah that's really
interesting i guess yeah
i wonder what is required to get the tax
credit
yeah and if they're doing something
different
what is that
i'm very i'm very curious more
information please yeah i definitely
want more information all right dylan
keller says hello do you remember the
episode of superman the animated series
when superman defeats darkseid and the
people now free rush to dark side crying
let me help you master neo libs reminded
me of it
i'm not familiar interesting
veronica
lavigna says
montreal was 8pm curfew but across a
short bridge in a suburb it's 9 30 p.m
but now it's all 9 30 p.m no seating in
restaurants yet weird oh yeah maybe it
was 9 30 this week
john hutto says babylon 5 is better than
ds9 some of the best writing in all
sci-fi in my honest opinion interesting
people keep saying that i have tried to
watch bab5 like
a half dozen times not into it i just
haven't it seems like it's almost too
soap operating
what about battlestar the new one i love
battlestar so good the new new one is
there a new no no no just like you know
from one show senior years ago that was
great
battle star dude
incredible
and the crazy creepy ending
dude that show is crazy it's like we
found a compatible species okay
joshua carpenter says when we say come
and take it understand it's an oath it's
oath breaking thugs in blue who will be
coming to take it for money i was just
doing my job did not work uh did not
work at nuremberg
someone has to take it
oh this is funny michael atkins says
bring brandon tatum on your show to your
show that's a good idea all right uh
we'll go back in time and we'll do that
because we did
he was cool
raleigh a murray says the defense i was
just doing what i was ordered to do did
not work well in the nuremberg trial i
thought it did work well in the
nuremberg didn't they let off a bunch of
nazis because they weren't the ones that
made the call and they just kind of cut
the head off like they killed no they
arrested a bunch of them for following
orders but then they released
almost everybody except for like a few a
lot of the soldiers who are just
right but a lot of people are just
following orders they got like
we have like a story just recently about
a nazi guy who's like 90 or something
they deported them back to germany
yeah
that's interesting when you look at like
blm right because you've had like
patrice cullers talk about how blm is a
leaderless movement which kind of makes
you think it's just a hydro when you cut
off one head
another one just springs forth in its
place it's a chaotic destructive force
that i think arises when there's a power
vacuum yeah and i think what we've seen
in america is that everybody basically
became kind of just complacent it's
easier just to lay back and say do
whatever you want just leave me alone
yeah and then well that's sort of what
everybody wants everyone just wants to
be left alone to to live their life
freely yeah you know but
we lost personal responsibility people
didn't want to stand up i mean i think
that was a problem at the very at the
beginning of this pandemic that's just
becoming exacerbated that's a big
problem the truth is even during the
revolution
the revolution era a lot of people like
a large chunk said i don't want to be
involved at all leave me alone i think
that's most people all the time and i
also think that that is some personal
responsibility like saying that you want
to live a a reasonable and quiet life
that should be perfectly acceptable
you got to earn that though that comes
at like the cost of life and death
people kill and protect our borders well
yeah you can live in calm sounds to
think that you're owed that but then you
know no i didn't i don't think that
you're owed it i'm saying people want it
and there's nothing wrong with wanting
it life is a treadmill if you stand
still you move backwards if you walk you
stay in the same place you have to run
to get start moving forward so
there are a lot of people who have been
made complacent by the people guarding
our borders and by the massive
technology technological superiority and
air superiority for the most part that
gives the u.s its dominance
and now because of that i think a lot of
people
you know power vacuums emerged in
politics where people are just saying i
abstain i don't want to be involved and
you end up with
people rioting and then even to this day
people are still saying i abstain it's
like they burned down a bunch of
buildings and you're still abstaining
from the vote okay man well i'm gonna
leave the city because i want to be
involved in it anymore we tried the
argument we tried arguing with people we
tried showing them we tried being you
know reasonable and rational and saying
look at this video man this is crazy
right and they still said i don't care
and i'm like bro the fire is making it
way to our house yeah and i said i'm not
gonna do this okay that was there was an
amazing thing in the summer with um
there was a protest in seattle and this
was actually i found to be the most
chilling of all the protests so there
was this protest and it was in the
evening it was at night it was dark and
it was a bunch of
kids teenagers 18 maybe
walking through a residential street
and they had a call in response and
it was
i'm fighting for you i'm fighting for
you i'm fighting for you
michaela we see you and they saw a girl
in the window
come out march with us march with us we
see you and i found that to be actually
the most chilling a bunch of children
walking down the street
saying that they're fighting for me and
demanding that people come come out of
their head with us yes it was
very much like that
it was the evil twins yeah that was i
thought terrifying but people still
after all of this said please just like
when when they voted for biden and
kamala after all the riots
they were on their knees begging please
burn more buildings down it was like it
was sort of a hostage situation that was
the deal was that we could have our
lives back i think that dark side
comment was was better
like
you know darkseid's the villain and when
he's defeated they all run say oh no
please please don't hurt master
so these people are suffering from
stockholm syndrome
yeah i think that's definitely true with
the democratic party yeah i think that's
definitely true
all right
trinidad shout out to pressure medical
care says when you say you have a good
library on tim cass you need to say it
in the trump voice the radical left
doesn't want you watching the
teamcast.com library
it's the best in the country
that's pretty good
caliber neutral says the chief of police
needs to be an elected official just
like sheriffs in the county
yeah maybe that's interesting but then
you still but then the democrats are
going to vote for democrats right you're
going to get some far left democrat
oh man i love it when the when the
superhero just jump and then it i'm like
where am i
all right let's see
how many people are mad at me over my my
stance on police lots of people all
right
andrew matina says she kicked your butt
tim yeah well there you go
all right let's see gareth green says
tim law enforcement is a valid function
of government and necessary for freedom
you are being defeatist no i'm i'm i'm
saying right now is people got to have
responsibility you can't just sit there
and be like cops should just be
responsible for for my safety not me and
they should pass laws taking away my
ability to defend myself if i so choose
people don't have guns they don't have
to have guns if i want to have guns i
should be allowed constitution says keep
and bear what do you think happens if
there's a con if there's a uh
a case brought against some of these
more restrictive
gun control laws there is have there
been right now the supreme court has
granted cert to
a suit
in new york you need a reason to get a
gun right they're challenging that so
that's cool and
or could be bad
in october i think october 4th could
always be bad that's always the option
so people are like it's six to three
it's conservative they're gonna win it's
like oh come on like it's they're fat
it's it's not no uh it's five to four at
best but uh the argument is
keep and bear arms means keep them like
in your home and and bear with them if
you like bear them meaning like you're
holding them you get to
right but uh we'll see they could say no
they could say if if if keeping and
bearing arms was for
a well-regulated militia
that doesn't mean you walk around with
guns it means you have the guns ready to
go in your home you can keep and use
however the bear in my opinion
there's no argument that makes sense
where it's like you can bear arms in
your house and nowhere else then they
wouldn't even add it to the constitution
at all yeah it's so interesting they
walked around with their guns
on purpose if you if you're supposed to
be in a militia and it's supposed to be
well functioning and you can't carry
your weapons around and then you're out
like in the field and then all of a
sudden like war breaks out they're like
quit come you're like hold on i have to
go to my storage to get my gun and then
i have to go to my other storage to get
my ammo yeah yeah then i have to put it
together separately because the law
that's right
sonny james says i think americans are
so rabid about their guns because the
government has broken every cultural
contract they've had with citizens their
seizing assets willy-nilly selectively
selectively punish policing
no transparency in federal shootings of
black men
boosted said
there was a documentary on prisons in
crime where several inmates openly
admitted they are much more afraid of a
private person with a gun than the
police an armed society is a polite
society
there was something i read about i don't
i don't know the full details but um
this was back when i i briefly took a
criminal justice course when i was like
18 for like two months
there was some jurisdiction in i think
like wisconsin maybe i'm not sure
that passed hardcore gun control and
then crime went up like 85 percent and
they immediately panicked and then like
rescinded the law and then crime went
right back down
yeah so like the issue is in chicago
they know you're not armed in west
virginia if you even get anywhere near
the wrong house they'll come out with a
gun being like
two more steps in the wrong direction
and you're not going to be alive anymore
and in st louis if you come out with a
gun you're going to get arrested that's
right even when they were like on their
own property
pc pierce says tim you went 30 plus
years being left in pro gun control in
one year people who didn't think like
you should have their cities burn give
people time
uh
i i i guess pro gun control is probably
fair but i was not anywhere near where
the democrats were i was actually fairly
pro-gun but my arguments were like well
there's probably some reforms we could
do and and some of these things might
make sense and then
someone commented on youtube videos
saying i completely agree i also think
that we should have some restrictions on
your ability to speak because i find
your videos offensive and i was like
okay i get it
and so now it's like that's exactly
where i landed on gun control that's
like how i got here well if you want to
change constitution change the
constitution if you don't then new york
shouldn't be enforcing
yeah legal gun laws i agree with that
well
they shouldn't have these kind of gun
control laws i think it should be easier
to buy a gun
let's see
godzilla 2k 26 says tim is completely
right tonight thank you i had to read
that one because the person who said
that you kicked my butt so i'm going to
read one that makes me sound a little a
little good we'll be fair we'll balance
and uh a lot of people saying an armed
society is a polite society
uh spidg vandersnatch says tim you're
removing options for non-violent
solutions not every vandal or thief
should be shot we need we need pros to
protect rights make it an honorable
profession again
i don't want people to get shot
however i do believe
that
for the most part unarmed society is a
polite society
that if someone knows there's
consequences to approaching you and
threatening your life they might not do
it i make the same argument for why
keeping and bearing arms second
amendment keeps us safe from government
tyranny not because as the left likes to
argue conservatives are going to go
march in the streets and challenge
tyrannical government
although some probably want to it's
because the police and the feds know
that if they kick your door in
you have a legal right to defend
yourself in your home and just like
briana taylor's boyfriend who shot that
cop in the leg the charges were dropped
so the government knows
we can't just kick doors in you better
get a warrant and do it right because
the dude in there might be armed look
what happens in these other countries i
mean there's one video right now from
the uk i think it's maybe it's from
ireland
they go into a guy's house
and they tell him that they're going to
be arresting him on like a medical
charge and he can't do anything about it
so they're like oh yeah we're
withholding you under because we're
afraid you're going to hurt yourself
they could theoretically do the same
thing here
there's a scary story though there was a
guy an older guy they were serving a red
flag that's like those yeah those red
flag laws well so the cops went to his
house the guy answered the door with his
gun they said we're here to take your
guns under red flag laws and he says you
know from my cold dead hands
so they fought him he got shot and
killed he got shot and killed yep i
thought it was he meant it sort of crazy
in columbus i think it was columbus ohio
just maybe it was last week there was um
they passed a law saying that
police could not use less lethal force
at protests at non-violent protests
and i thought but
can't they still use their guns like
what are you doing so they can no longer
use less lethal force that's correct
that's correct so what are they supposed
to do if the protest turns into a riot
then what yep it's crazy and they're
they're not even supposed to have it on
them like what is the deal
well you could buy a rubber buckshot
you know so it's good for scaring away
animals i guess if you've got you know i
don't know depends on what everyone's
got different opinions on when you
should or shouldn't use them i've been
told by people never to use them because
if you point a gun at somebody who's a
threat to you you don't want to give
them a chance to be the threat to you
right but i really don't want to kill
somebody you know like even like it's
scary you know someone breaks into your
house and they're armed for lethal force
and they're going to end your life and
you need to protect yourself
it's still probably naive to be like but
i really don't want that person to die
you know what i mean but it's it's not
naive to say that you don't want that
person to die i mean you're saying that
killing someone would have a negative
effect on you as a person
and it would have a negative effect on
you right like so you kill somebody
and
that's not going to leave you that you
killed somebody that's going to stay
with you do you want that on your
conscience no matter what that person
did i mean do you want to have to like i
don't i don't i don't see it that way um
for me at least i if i was forced into
into a situation where i know i have to
defend myself or someone else i accept
that sure you can accept it but i think
no matter what we do when we do
something that
um like
for example when you commit like there's
a there's a couple of different kinds of
commandments right in the ten
commandments so there's the kind where
you sin against god there's the kind
where
you sin against others and there's the
kind where you sin against yourself
right so why do you not covet your
neighbor's wife you don't covet your
neighbor's wife because not because of
the harm it does anyone else the harm it
does you
so when you commit a sin or when you do
something
that
you know
there's ways that you can harm yourself
in doing that so i can understand why
even in a situation
where you would be defending yourself
you would maybe say
that you don't necessarily want to
[Music]
have to kill someone even if you can
justify it later even if you can
perfectly well understand that you were
within your rights and that it was the
only thing you could do you're still
carrying that with you right i
understand that point for me it's mostly
about the other person it's about this
idea where
you know when i was younger i just
thought about the concept of the death
penalty imagining someone in a position
where their life is snuffed out and the
experience they go through and what it
means to end a unique
individual no matter how bad that person
might be
is
it's like
i don't know i don't know describe it
but it's an ex it's an exertion of power
beyond what i think we should be i
totally agree i'm 100 opposed to capital
punishment yeah so no matter no matter
what the no matter what the wretched
miserable crime i know it's tough isn't
it yeah yeah so even if someone's
breaking in they want to hurt me i'm
like
they might be bad people but i'm not bad
people that's what i'm saying that's
tough but but it is naive because a lot
of people i talked to defense experts
say well then you'll die right i mean
it's interesting too like the quaker
position
um the quaker position is non-violence
no matter what like never
taking up arms against someone else even
to defend yourself but then you could
also say like uh you know in in that
case
if no one life is better than any others
then why is the life of the person who's
trying to kill me better than mine
that's interesting too it's a you know
it's definitely worth philosophical
examination
gold 818 says sorry tim but i think she
got you on this argument sure an
individual may be able to protect
themselves against another individual
but good luck when a gang comes in and
invades your property watch the walking
dead all right well my my opinion is
that an armed society is a polite
society and i think you need
neighborhood watch
you know i was reading about the
formation of police departments it was
interesting because the left likes to
claim that they were formed from slave
patrols that's actually not true
actually not true yeah it's funny
uh
there are some
some police departments did but mostly
not it was just the concept of local
policing that was being implemented in
certain countries and then it was
eventually brought over here for a
variety of reasons and the interesting
thing is that before police we had local
militias
just had community watch people were
responsible for themselves and then they
brought in policing i think we face a
very serious problem as a civilization
especially one with classically liberal
roots due to the population due to
population density
the the more
i talked to you i i mentioned this
before and ian gotta kick out of this
because you're into physics
the more people are
the further you are away your bubble of
rights is massive
you live in the middle of nowhere you go
outside you can you know if you
literally live in the middle of nowhere
you can be pretty irresponsible with you
know dangerous stuff there's no one
around right you can have a gender
reveal party in the middle of nowhere
right hope well i mean just as long as
you're not near the forest because
um but then as you get to the you get
from from absolute rural where you have
like 200 acres of your own property
there's no one in anywhere and you're in
between the saddle of two mountains and
you can fire into the backstop let you
do whatever you want for the most part
you're not going to hurt anybody you
still got to be careful about you know
causing damage to the environment for
sure then you get closer to the suburbs
and your sphere of right starts going
down because now you have people not too
far away and now you can't use guns
because
even if you have backstop it's probably
gonna be noisy you've got to be careful
about what time you're doing certain
things then you move into the cities and
your rights become this microscopic
bubble because now everyone's competing
with each other over your rights now to
clarify everybody's rights are
immutable inalienable but the problem is
civil disputes erupt so what happens is
i don't want you to have a gun because
we are you know we're all sitting right
next to each other and someone could be
irresponsible and the bullet could end
up hurting a bunch of people
and my argument is the constitution
doesn't say population density affects
your right to keep and bear arms but
people in cities don't care and they
vote for things because they're in
conflict with each other so i view it
kind of like the states of matter
when when you condense everyone into a
cubicle brick and they're all stacked on
top of each other it becomes like a
solid matter where you can't you're not
really free to move all that much you
move on to the suburbs it's more liquid
and you can move around you still have
some ability to do things are kind of
out of the ordinary and then you have
the gaseous state which is in the middle
of nowhere where you can basically do
whatever you want and you're free to
bounce around and go crazy yeah and then
we'll have plasma state where people are
in outer space drifting teleportation
plasma state that thing where you're
looking in the person's eyes on the
oxytocin as well
right
all right christian schultz says
legalize mutual unarmed combat all right
all right
we'll just read one more right here
uh
it just says dash loving this bombshell
pro-america political discourse the
disagreement on this footage are
consistently incredibly based libby are
you radical left
oh man
no no definitely not
uh okay my friends if you haven't
already smash the like button head over
to timcast.com and become a member
because we will have an exclusive
members only segment coming up at about
11 o'clock and don't forget to follow us
facebook.com teamcast irl if you're not
already subscribe to this channel and
we're also on instagram because on
facebook you can help share the videos
we put up clips every day and help
spread the word we're going to be doing
more and more of our timcast.com it's
going to be really really awesome so
become a member exclusive segment coming
up soon you can follow me at timcast
everywhere and my other youtube channels
are youtube.comcast and youtube.com
do you have anything you want to shout
out libby uh yeah shout out the post
millennial we're at
thepostmillennial.com
ryan i'm ian crosson at iancrossland.net
and at ian crossland across social media
thanks
and i am sour patch lids on twitter if
you guys want to follow me there
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you